merci donc monsieur le Président de vous
êtes rendu disponible et j'en profite
puisque nous avons et nous allons
auditionner plusieurs des représentants
de votre groupe pour remercier la
direction des affaires publiques de la
SNCF de nous avoir facilité ces prises
de rendez-vous monsieur le Président
nous avons déjà auditionné madame midrac
la semaine dernière et je le disais nous
entendrons après vous monsieur Gallois
puis monsieur Pepy c'est-à-dire quatre
dirigeants pour une période de 27 ans
à la tête du groupe public ferroviaire
et ça devrait nous permettre et c'est
l'un des premiers objectifs vous le
savez il y a deux dimensions dans cette
commission d'enquête cela devrait donc
nous permettre première de ces
dimensions de retracer ce qui nous a
amené à la situation actuelle en matière
de frais de ferroviaire et finalement a
constaté un redressement en 2021-2022 du
point de vue de la part modale à
redressement financier aussi de fêter
SNCF sur la même période
mais qui succède à une période de déclin
de la part modale on est revenu déjà
dans les auditions précédentes à de
nombreuses reprises sur des facteurs que
nous avions les uns les autres bien en
tête
à savoir
les difficultés liées à l'infrastructure
à la fois à son état mais aussi à
l'attribution des sillons et donc à sa
fréquentation les difficultés liées à la
prise en compte de l'activité fret à
l'échelle d'une grande stratégie
nationale dans lesquelles elle pouvait
répondre à des objectifs de politique
publique qui ne soient pas que ceux de
l'aménagement du territoire et on s'est
aperçu à cet égard que la le lien entre
l'activité Fred ferroviaire et la
possibilité de décarboner les transports
ou pour le dire comme on le disait au
début des années 2000 de préserver
l'environnement ce lien n'était pas
vraiment fait de façon systématique
avant une période relativement récente
et puis la deuxième dimension du de
notre travail vous le savez c'est
évidemment de revenir sur la solution de
discontinuité qui a été proposée par le
gouvernement pour et c'est ce que nous a
dit le miser transport pour faire suite
ou protéger fêter SNCF à la suite de
l'enquête approfondie qui a été ouverte
le 18 janvier dernier sur les aides
publiques regardez par la Commission
européenne comme
pouvant être indus perçu par fret SNCF
nous serions donc heureux monsieur le
Président que vous reveniez
sur ce contentieux qui visait Fred SNCF
avec qui c'était ouvert en 2016 donc
quand vous avez pris vos fonctions en
octobre 2019
sous contentieux était déjà ouvert mais
sous l'angle des plaintes lancées par
les concurrents de fret SNCF
sur les conséquences aussi qu'il y a eu
la réorganisation du grand public
ferroviaire à la suite de la loi portant
pacte ferroviaire de 2018 sur l'état de
cette plainte on sait qu'il y a des
interrogations dans la commission
d'enquête on les partage pas tous mais
sur l'effet transformation en épique et
passage à la SA sur la manière dont
c'est ces enquêtes ou ce regard de la
Commission européenne a pu être jetée ou
être rendu plus plus aiguë on souhaitait
également que vous nous expliquiez
comment la SNCF aujourd'hui le groupe
public ferroviaire regarde l'activité
frette là où certains d'entre nous au
fil des auditions de la semaine dernière
on peut avoir le sentiment qu'au sein du
groupe public ferroviaire l'activité
fret n'avait pas toujours été une
priorité dans le fonctionnement
de de la Société des ensembles de
sociétés que représente SNCF
comment voyez-vous cette cette reprise
de Sion qu'on a évoqué avec Frédéric
Delorme tout à l'heure c'est-à-dire ces
23 sillons que SNCF red va devoir céder
comment voyez-vous les sessions d'actifs
qui sont prévus aussi dans ce plan de
discontinuité et comment évaluez-vous le
risque d'un report modal inversé qui
préoccupe évidemment beaucoup cette
commission est sur lesquels monsieur
Delorme c'est montré plutôt rassurant il
y a quelques minutes dans cette même
salle quelques heures déjà monsieur le
Président je vous laisserai la parole
pour une intervention liminaire d'une
dizaine de minutes puis les collègues
qui le souhaitent pourront poser des
questions après les questions du
rapporteur et du président auparavant je
vous rappelle que l'article 6 de
l'ordonnance du 17 novembre 1958
relative au fonctionnement des
assemblées parlementaires impose aux
personnes qui sont auditionnées par les
commissions d'enquête de prêter serment
de dire la vérité toute la vérité rien
que la vérité je vais donc vous inviter
à lever la main droite et à dire je le
jure
je le jure je vous remercie monsieur le
Président vous avez la parole
merci monsieur le Président je salue
bien sûr monsieur rapporteur monsieur
les mesdames les membres de la
commission
peut-être avant de commencer sur le fond
quelques éléments de
contexte vous dire que ce qui arrive
aujourd'hui au groupe SNCF et après SNCF
peut être que fait-on le qualifie de
difficile
je pense que pour pour un dirigeant
d'entreprise
organisé volontairement la réduction de
l'activité et de manière substantielle
et peut-être des éléments les plus
compliqués qu'on qu'on puisse faire
c'est antinomique avec le rôle d'un
dirigeant qui est développé sur
l'entreprise donc c'est difficile
pour les dirigeants c'est pas très c'est
pas le plus important le c'est surtout
difficile pour les hommes et les femmes
qui constituent fratés SNCF
il faut se mettre à leur place c'est pas
quelque chose qui est simple
d'autant plus on a affaire à des gens
qui depuis longtemps mais enfin je peux
en témoigner depuis que je suis
président SNCF comme vous l'avez rappelé
fin octobre début novembre 2019 on a on
a pu noter leur engagement on l'a vu
dans le covid ou on se souvient qu'au
début dans un contexte où les
protections des salariés étaient pas
complètement parfaite ils n'ont jamais
refinis à faire rouler les trains de les
trains essentiel pour l'économie du pays
les carburants les produits qui
permettaient de traiter l'eau les
médicaments enfin ils ont été là
ils ont été là à la reprise aussi quand
quand l'économie a pu repartir
donc on a affaire à des gens courageux
qui on le rappelle et vous l'avez vous
le percevez certainement au travers des
des auditions bah ils ont ils ont ils
ont une quinzaine d'années de
restructuration derrière eux allez dire
donc forcément ce sont des gens
encourageeux qui ont fait face à cette
période difficile
vous m'avez posé la question donc j'y
réponds tout de suite
c'est une question qu'il faut poser
est-ce que est-ce que l'activité de
transport ne marchandises et stratégique
pour le groupe SNCF au fond il faut la
poser aussi simplement que ça moi je
vais répondre pour moi bon après les
autres répondront pour chacun pour moi
la réponse est oui c'est stratégique
d'ailleurs dans dans le
dans la mission dans la mission
l'ambition stratégique de l'entreprise
il y a bien le d'être champion de
développement durable par le par le
ferroviaire voyageur et marchandises
parce que la méta mission le mettait
engagement c'est bien 35 écologique en
fait c'est de comprendre que le pour moi
il est clair que le ferroviaire fait
partie de la solution par rapport à
l'enjeu énorme qui est d'adapté notre
industrie nos consommations nos manières
d'être etc à ce défi formidable et qu'en
termes de mobilité au fond qui est le
secteur qui est le mien le ferroviaire
doit jouer un rôle peut jouer un rôle ce
qu'on appelle le report modal pour faire
en sorte que des marchandises et des
voyageurs aujourd'hui transport dans les
mots de plus impactant sur
l'environnement puisse passer au train
voilà donc oui j'ai répondu de manière
explicite et non pas implicite
transporter des marchandises en train
fait partie des activités stratégiques
de l'entreprise voilà même si
aujourd'hui le chiffre d'affaires n'est
plus modeste comme paraît voyager qui
s'est beaucoup développé il n'empêche
que il faut le faire d'autant plus que
j'ai la conviction que à court moyen
long terme c'est une activité qui va se
développer voilà on y reviendra
peut-être dans la cour d'exposer mais
donc c'est une bonne décision
stratégique à la fois bien sûr sur le
fond participer de la transition
écologique par le report modal en haut
de la route vers le vers le train et
deuxièmement c'est une activité qui peut
trouver son équilibre économique dans la
durée et
s'auto s'auto alimenter s'auto suffire
en matière en matière économique
troisième élément un peu de contexte je
c'est c'est tout à fait légitime que que
des élus nanation des parlementaires
s'intéressent à ce sujet parce que ce
sujet voilà il est un des composants du
débat sur la transition écologique
deuxièmement dans les territoires dans
plusieurs territoires il y a une envie
de ferroviaire qui entraîne de se
manifester parce que les parties des
entreprises aussi c'est le fameux Cup 3
entreprises qu'on commence à comprendre
que pour réduire le stop 3 elles doivent
inciter leur transporteur à la fois les
pour amener les matières premières
nécessaires ou pour ensuite emporter les
produits qu'ils ont fabriqués à faire
moins recours au camion et davantage au
train voilà donc comme la responsabilité
sur le scope 3 elle va grandissant dans
les bilans carbone des entreprises il y
a une appétit aussi des entreprises dans
les territoires pour recourir davantage
au train voilà donc on est on est sur
des enjeux importants sans parler des
enjeux sociaux parce qu'il y a aussi un
jeu sociaux dans ce dossier qui peuvent
toucher plus particulièrement quelques
endroits du territoire dans l'Est dans
le sud
ou ailleurs
alors vous l'avez dit et donc je pense
que c'est maintenant certainement une
image qui doit se préciser dans dans vos
têtes le secteur le secteur du fret est
en difficulté structurelle alors on sait
pas quand ça remonte
on dit souvent les 2000 mais en fait je
pense que dès les années 80 il y a une
inversion de tendance moi qui suis un
vieux cheminot à la fin des années 70
début des années 80 avant le TGV quoi en
gros
les gens de la SNCF considéraient que le
fret était l'activité principale et
majeure de l'entreprise alors c'est la
France des années 70 et 80 c'est la
France industrielle il y a encore de la
chirurgie il y a encore des mines il y a
encore tout ça quoi bon forcément ça va
avec
bon voilà Monsieur Président vous êtes
issu d'une région qui connaît bien ça et
c'est vrai qu'il y a une inflexion un
peu un peu sournoise j'allais dire pas
forcément visible comme toute inflexion
on la voit pas forcément au début où il
y a voilà pour des facteurs
divers donc celui-là la France devient
moins industrielle d'ailleurs les
clients naturels du train ont
disparraissent petit à petit au même
moment le voyageur qui s'est développé
le TGV dans un premier temps les terres
grâce à la reprise par les régions de de
la compétence sur les trains régionaux
une espèce de vaste communicant un peu
implicite qui s'est mis en place
plus de traine voyageurs moins de train
de marchandises
aggravé par des conditions au même
moment la route qu'on est des gains de
productivité considérables donc voilà
donc tout ça tout ça bouge dans le
mauvais sens il y a une forme
d'alignement négatif des planètes qui
petit à petit conduit le trafic
ferroviaire a sorti à sortir de sa zone
de pertinence et on enclenche une phase
de déclin bon certains ont tenté de
l'arrêter et tentative je pensais
sincère d'arrêter ce déclin ça a
toujours été compliqué ou en tout cas ça
n'a pas complètement réussi à infléchir
cette tendance
pour moi d'ailleurs je peux tout de
suite évoquer les pourquoi au fond parce
que la question se pose d'autant plus
certains pays en Europe ont réussi donc
c'est toujours intéressant de se dire
pourquoi certains réussissent pas nous
parce que c'est quand même une bonne
question même si leur structure
industrielle n'est pas la même etc il y
a des éléments qui sont pas pareil il y
a quand même bon en fait et vous l'avez
aussi cité dans votre introduction
monsieur le Président
pour que le fret fonctionne il faut des
politiques publiques c'est à dire qu'il
y a pas du tout de politique publique en
particulier pour le wagon isolé s'il est
un peu livré à lui-même aux lois du
marché un wagon isolé c'est 40 tonnes un
camion c'est 40 tonnes un wagon contre
un camion on va tout de suite la
souplesse du camion en termes de dessert
etc et de rotation le wagon et le petit
locotracteur pour aller l'amener chez le
client le remplir le ramener
l'incorporer dans un train un triage de
triage le livret ça met trois jours ça
met quatre jours le camion il a fait
trois ou quatre fois l'aller-retour donc
forcément on voit bien que d'une manière
assez implacable s'il y a pas
d'intervention publique le camion il va
gagner contre isolé voilà c'est ce qui
s'est passé d'ailleurs c'est ce qu'on a
constaté et et dans d'autres pays où
justement on a fait des choix
d'engagement d'engagement de politique
publique en faveur du wagon isolé mais
ça mieux tenu voilà on passe à
l’autriche on pense à l'Allemagne on
pense à d'autres bon nous ça a pas été
le cas
deuxièmement et c'est là aussi il faut
il faut être clair c'est la qualité des
sillons les trains de fret seront
aujourd'hui ne circule plus le jour très
peu puisque le graphique d'occupation
des voies étaient largement consommées
par les trains voyageurs et tant mieux
quelque part on se peut que se féliciter
de voir que ce trafic voyageur qui a
démarré donc ils sont envoyés enfin les
trains de long parcours à la nuit la
nuit il y a des travaux donc c'est pas
toujours simple de passer les trains
dont les sillons sont pas très bonne
qualité les vitesses commerciales alors
que techniquement en train de
marchandise peut rouler à 100 km/h il y
a pas de problème mais en fait il roule
la vitesse commerciale n'est pas de 100
km/h parce qu'il est garé tous les 200
km il est garé pendant une heure deux
heures etc et donc on arrive à des
vitesses commerciales plutôt de 30 km/h
au lieu de 100 km/h donc quand vous
combinez tous ces facteurs on voit bien
que les facteurs économiques les
facteurs industriels les facteurs de
service forcément vont vendre dans le
mauvais sens voilà donc
ça c'est des sujets bien sûr très très
importants qui explique enfin l'absence
de ces de ces facteurs là et
certainement à mon avis il a été
constituent les causes racines de ce
phénomène de déclin que vous avez
constaté et ça veut donc dire que si on
veut amorcer une courbe de progression
casser cette spirale déclin va donc
falloir traiter ces deux facteurs des
aides structurelles au secteur et des
choix d'infrastructures qui permettront
d'avoir des Sion de qualité etc voilà
donc c'est c'est je pense qu'il faut il
faut savoir le dire sans problème
Fret SNCF aussi il y a un épisode qu'il
faut citer c'est l'ouverture à la
concurrence
elle est souvent rappelée d'ailleurs par
les organisations syndicales et ils ont
raison ça peut être une réussite voilà
c'est à dire que le fait de dire il
suffit d'ouvrir la concurrence pour que
le secteur se développe a été battu en
brèche voilà ça suffit pas
alors certes ça met un peu d'émulation
certains mais un peu de nouveaux acteurs
ça ça mais au fond et la démonstration
en est faite ça n'a pas permis de
développer l'activité puisqu'on
transporte moins aujourd'hui une
marchandise qu'on a transporté en 2007
quand la quand le secteur c'est ouvert
donc
le débat sur la concurrence est un autre
débat c'est pas le vôtre mais mais on
peut en conclure et peut-être ces
conclusions servira-t-elle à d'autres
d'autres à d'autres secteurs que la
concurrence peut peut-être avoir un
effet de de stimulation du marché si des
politiques publiques créent les
conditions de développement du marché
voilà donc si on a si on cumule
concurrence et développement là on a
certainement une dynamique intéressante
voilà mais si on ne fait que concurrence
là on a un problème voilà donc je pense
que c'est peut-être une des conclusion
qu'il faut tirer de de cette de cette
période et d'ailleurs là encore en
termes de leçons on en revient ça crée
on les conditions du développement et là
que peut-être la concurrence retrouvera
une action de stimulation du marché
qu'elle n'a pas pu avoir jusqu'à
maintenant
on a évoqué les coûts sociaux bon ils
sont ils sont de deux natures les coûts
sociaux donc c'est vrai qu'il y a
quelques coups sociaux supérieurs à Fret
SNCF qui qui perd dans toute cette
période était une composante à part
entière de la grande SNCF en fait il y
avait des divisions internes mais le
passage en société ne date que de que de
2020 de la réforme de 2020 et les
conditions sociales sont sont toujours
les mêmes il y a
les coûts sociaux vous avez les les
coûts de les coûts supplémentaires du
régime spécial de retraite le fameux T2
la surcotisation T2 qui est pas
négligeable je crois que c'est 10% de
cotisations supplémentaires c'est quand
même pas rien bon ça pèse et vous avez
aussi le
réglementation du du du du travail le
fameux rh-77 dans notre dans notre
jurgon qui est un peu plus contraignant
et donc conduit parfois des
productivités du travail un peu
inférieur à celle que les concurrents
peuvent fournir voilà c'est en gros les
il peut y en avoir une troisième alors
je sais pas si c'est pas le même nature
mais je crois qu'il faut l'évoquer par
honnêteté intellectuelle même sans
aucunement
aucune volonté polémique de ma part les
conditions sociales de cette période qui
sont des conditions compliquées il y
avait plusieurs réformes profondes etc
on crée quand même un climat social
difficile il faut être clair ce qui m'a
social difficile a pu conduire à des
moments de grève on sait que les
mouvements de grève ont un effet quand
même négatifs en tout cas sur Fred voir
même sur le secteur voilà donc la
combinaison de tout ça on voit bien
est un des enjeux de la période et
peut-être que là aussi faudra réfléchir
à des débuts de solution des ou des
apports de solutions par rapport à ces
difficultés qu'on peut poser sur le
développement du fret en général le fret
SNCF en particulier pour tout ça conduit
une dette vous l'avez évoqué
cette dette elle est assez on sait d'où
elle vient on sait la reconstituer
d'ailleurs elle était calculée il est
analytique qu'on appelle donc elle n'est
pas comptable puisqu'il n'y avait pas de
société à part mais elle était
analytique 50% c'est la somme des
déficits cumulée année après année
puisque depuis 2007 on est en déficit
bon bah ça fait déficit accumulé
constitue une dette qui est
effectivement a été compensé par là par
la société mère à l'époque c'est pas aux
idées c'est des SNCF effectivement c'est
du vrai argent c'est ce déficit c'est
des fournisseurs c'est des salaires
c'est des approches c'est du vrai argent
c'est pas de là c'est pas l'argent sur
papier c'est vrai l'argent il faut bien
il faut bien l'amener deuxièmement les
fameux surcosociaux on l'évacue à 25% du
total
[Musique]
n'était pas là et c'est quand même
l'État qui est un interface avec avec la
Commission au fond on est toujours sur
la ligne que ce qu'on a fait et
juridiquement acceptable
tout ça s'est fait en transparence
on dit aussi que nous on croit que dans
la durée l'activité du frais de
ferroviaire va se redresser donc même si
c'est du temps long c'est de
l'investissement à Visé de soutenir
cette activité parce qu'un jour ou
l'autre elle finira par passer dans le
verre donc c'est pas déraisonnable un
plan économique de la soutenir on met en
avant bien sûr tous les tous les
avantages
externes de ces investissements pour
pour dire au fond il y a un peu
d'intérêt général là-dedans on était une
entreprise publique
c'est pas des raisonnable ce qu'elle
fait et c'est voilà c'est ça peut être
acceptable de soutenir cette cette
activité
tout ça dure un certain temps arrive la
réforme de 2000 lois 2018 mais mise en
place en 2020
sur fond de ces discussions déjà
engagées je pense que
l'État et le groupe SNCF espèrent avoir
progressé dans la région ils ont du
problème c'est pas jusqu'à son terme est
progresser un en faisant de fraises une
vraie société ça c'était une demande
ancienne de la commission d'isolée
quelque part de rendre autonome au plan
économique et commercial frais et SNCF
on le fait dans sous forme de société
anonyme simplifiée donc c'est fait 2 il
y a cette société il faut la noter d'un
capital on fixe à 70 millions d'euros
bon on peut toujours discuter il m'a
fait des pas normal que cette société
est un capital donc elle la donne d'un
capital et reste le sujet de la dette le
raisonnement de l'État français de du
groupe SNCF il est clair d'ailleurs
cette société ne peut pas supporter 5
milliards peut-être elle a pas elle a
pas la surface financière pour le porter
cette dette existe on a ni par les
licence de cette dette il faut la loger
quelque part on la laisse on la loge
dans la société de tête voilà elle est
là on le dit à tout le monde c'est
quelque chose qui est connu qui n'est
pas caché qui est transparent et ces
éléments des informations seront donnés
à la commission bon
[Musique]
avec dans la foulée de la constitution
de la SAS Frat SNCF on arrive à lever
les plaintes bon voilà les discussions
se font on arrive à lever les plaintes
et donc en une situation qui est propre
entre guillemets il a levé des plaintes
et c'est un argument qu'on a utilisé
peut être perçu comme même nos
concurrents privés reconnaissent que les
choses se sont rangées il n'y a plus de
d'intervention illégale de l'État il n'y
a plus de distorsion de marché en tout
cas c'est l'interprétation conana et
d'ailleurs je crois que certaines de nos
concurrents l'écrivent dans la levée des
plaintes ils écrivent clairement que
dorénavant les choses se sont alors
avant ils disent toujours que ça va pas
mais dorénavant on a une situation qui
peut être considérée comme satisfaisante
au vu du droit de la concurrence donc au
fond on a le sentiment que c'est
derrière nous on a une nouvelle phase
qui s'ouvre
le plan de relance donne l'occasion à
l'état français de d'aider fêter cette
pour la première fois ces historique du
coup donc le secteur est aidé une partie
de l'aide à arriver à fêter SNCF qui est
capable de sortir un résultat positif en
tout cas sur le recto opérationnel
c'était pas arrivé depuis longtemps on a
même retournement du marché on a une
part de modèle qui augmente donc
j'allais dire les signaux pour nous pour
moi sont considérés comme ovaires
clignotant en tout cas en tout cas on
n'a pas le sentiment qu'on est en
situation
elle est meilleure on apprécie même une
situation qui est meilleur par rapport à
thé bon pour autant je suis honnête avec
la Commission on n'a jamais eu un feu
vert explicite de la de la Commission
européenne bon mais bon on a le
sentiment que les choses sont en
meilleure état sur ce sur ce dossier là
et je dois dire que j'étais surpris
honnêtement de de ressentir un
durcissement de la commission via l'État
français le Gee etc à partir de
l'automne alors là pour des raisons donc
que je me dont je mets ce que je
m'explique pas voilà j'ai pas j'ai pas
l'explication pourquoi ce durcissement
mais il est réel
le ton monte mais les arguments se
durcissent et on commence à avoir évoqué
un scénario à la à l'Italia pour la
première fois apparaître cet élément
dans le paysage
bon je pense que le gouvernement
multiplie ses efforts pour pour éviter
l'ouverture et l'ouverture à Dieu voilà
bon donc là on est dans la phase 3 on a
l'ouverture depuis janvier
ce qui change la donne parce que là pour
le coup on est un peu dos au mur bon et
là bon le ministre Clément bonne ou il a
expliqué le choix qu'il a fait bon je je
je reviens pas sur le choix
mais je vais être honnête avec vous moi
je je je soutiens ce choix je veux dire
que prendre le risque d'aller au
tribunal et de perdre un risque fatal
donc
si la commission ouvre c'est qu'elle
pense qu'elle a des arguments je veux
dire solides alors tant que c'est pas
jugé il y a toujours un petit doute mais
quand même on les connaît c'est pas des
gens qui qui s'avancent de manière
légère donc on pense qu'ils ont un fond
juridique solide et bon le ministre
c'est sa responsabilité de décider
on a aidé le ministre à dans notre rôle
de de défense de la SNCF et des
cheminots à mettre en place on a pris
des lignes rouges
voilà donc c'est lignes rouges vous
aurez été rappelé
premièrement et je commencerai à
l'envers moi la première ligne rouge que
je décide moi c'est pas le ministre
c'est moi qui la décide c'est protéger
les cheminots concernés et leur offrir
un débouché dans le groupe quoi qu'il
arrive voilà quoi qu'il arrive on a déjà
commencé il y a des discussions le
transfert principal étant de du fret
vers le TER c'est quand même ça qui va
se passer c'est pas le seul mais c'est
ce sera le courant principal et il y a
plusieurs régions on a déjà commencé à
regarder notamment Occitanie avec
Perpignan etc bon ça tombe bien on a des
besoins dans le thé vert donc voilà on
doit pouvoir arriver à trouver une place
pas trop loin de chez soi à chaque
cheminot du frais de concerné c'est
plutôt des conducteurs pas que mais
plutôt des conducteurs bon ça c'est un
engagement j'ai un peu solennel interne
que j'ai pu prendre devant les cheminots
et les cheminots et les organisations
syndicales ensuite on est sur les
engagements plus il y a un deuxième
engagement qui est important c'est que
ce qui ressortira de ce process soit
viable dans la durée il s'agit pas de
secret un problème deux ans après sinon
voilà il faut vraiment créer l'écho et
là je vous en d'État j'ai besoin de
l'État pour faire en sorte que le que
c'est la nouvelle société qui va doit
être recentrée sur le ce qu'on appelle
le mutualiser ou les triages pour faire
simple et les conditions économiques qui
puissent lui donner de vraies
perspectives à la fois de vivre et de se
développer et de se développer parce
qu'on vous le développement et là ça
passe par le double
il faut marcher sur deux pattes les
aides les aides à l'exploitation et
l'infrastructure on a besoin des deux et
de manière assez solide massive et
rapide pour enclencher la marche avant
bien sûr éviter absolument le report
modal parce que si on fait tout ça pour
qu'il y a davantage de marchandises sur
le camion c'est pas terrible
voilà en gros les les les principes
j'allais dire les lignes rouges qu'on a
souhaité poser bon après le ministre les
a discuté
après la suite vous la connaissez
moi pour terminer je franchement
j'espère comprenez ma sincérité quand je
vous dis que je en tant que président du
groupe SNCF je me serais passé de devoir
conduire ce dossier au sein au sein du
groupe ou de demander au patron de
prêter SNCF de le conduire avec l'appui
du groupe c'est pas du tout une bonne
nouvelle du tout du tout bon maintenant
on a ça c'est ma responsabilité
dirigeante de le faire en protégeant au
maximum les cheminots et en protégeant
le pôle fret de notre groupe parce que
moi je souhaite qui est un pôle Fred
dans notre groupe qui puisse se se
développer
comme toujours c'est un peu ma
philosophie de la vie j'aime bien le mot
faire du judo c'est un coup dont on
serait passé si ce coût permet de poser
les conditions
durable solide
réel concrète d'un vrai développement du
Fred ferroviaire dans notre pays avec un
vrai avenir pour le pôle public que
représente le fret SNCF ou ce qu'il
deviendra au sein du groupe SNCF
voilà là on aura on aura une sortie
honorable une vraie perspective et
d'ailleurs pour moi et vous le savez
même si c'est pas le thème de cette
commission mais mais ça me paraît
évident pour moi en fait cet ensemble
fret est un sous-ensemble de du plan
important d'avenir pour les transports
qu'il faut poser dans ce pays parce que
ça rejoint le voyageur tout se tient le
réseau il est unique quelque part il
pète plus ou moins dédié mais il y a une
grande partie du réseau ferroviaire qui
est commun aux voyageurs et aux fret
donc pour ranger le fret il faut ranger
le réseau il faut trouver des capacités
voilà de tout ça au fond on se tient
donc si on arrive et j'ai besoin des
parlementaires là-dessus j'ai besoin des
parlementaires parce qu'au fond on n'est
pas loin d'une loi tout ça ça peut se
terminer par une loi ça peut loi de
silence loi de programmation voilà moi
au fond si si
cet événement fâcheux peut comme c'est
en train de s'être fait amener de
l'intérêt des parlementaires à ce sujet
une action des parlementaires pour créer
les conditions de développement du
ferroviaire dans ce pays notamment au
fret au moins on aura on aura pas
travaillé pour rien
bien merci monsieur le Président donc
comme on le fait pour toutes les
personnes auditionnées quelques
questions d'abord à mon niveau puis
ensuite je passerai la parole à Monsieur
le rapporteur
d'abord
deux questions qui portent sur le
ce regard finalement de la de la
Commission européenne sur les aides
publiques et le raisonnement qui est
tenu
est-ce que le fait que la reprise de la
dette par le groupe de tête la dette de
fret SNCF les 5 milliards 3 le fait que
ce soit à peu près concomitant avec la
reprise de la dette de la SNCF au sens
large
par l'État est-ce que c'est cela qui
pose problème c'est une question qui je
le qui a un moment donné plané dans la
dans la discussion mais puisque les deux
les deux choses se font en même temps et
est-ce que c'est le raisonnement que
tient la Commission européenne on peut
l'imaginer mais je voudrais que ce soit
un peu explicité parce qu'en soit au
sein d'un groupe qui est une solidarité
du groupe d'une partie vers une autre en
soit n'est pas constitutive d'une aide
publique de façon organique il faut il
faut pouvoir le regarder la deuxième
chose c'est que
majorité de régulation des transports
qui s'appelaient peut-être encore la
raffaire à l'époque avait au moment de
la transformation du du groupe public
ferroviaire donc du passage des épiques
aux sociétés anonymes elle avait alerté
sur le risque juridique que représentait
la reprise de la dette de fret SNCF
est-ce que vous vous souvenez de cet
avis puisqu'il a été formulé une à un
moment où vous étiez déjà ou peut-être
très légèrement avant président du
groupe public ferroviaire et comment
vous expliquer que cette alerte n'est
pas été suivie forcément d'une forme de
prise de conscience
[Musique]
dans un paysage ou il y avait peu de
soutien public sauf à SNCF pendant
longtemps et aujourd'hui en fait il y en
a plus
c'est à peu près ce que vous nous avez
décrit et puis dernier point vous
évoquiez un instant et on a questionné
Frédéric Delorme sur ce sujet aussi tout
à l'heure je crois que c'était monsieur
le rapporteur qu'il avait fait
sur les questions sociales et notamment
sur la manière dont concrètement
les transferts de personnels ou
l'évolution des perspectives
professionnelles du personnel pouvaient
se faire pour ceux qui sont concernés
pour les 20% de trafic et donc les 10%
de personnels et les 30% de chiffre
d'affaires à céder c'est à dire sur les
trains longs complets dédiés
vous nous disiez à l'instant que une
part significative des conducteurs
allait être distribué au sein du groupe
public ferroviaire
ce que l'on peut comprendre puisque
effectivement il y a une demande de
train voyageur qui est très forte
comment évaluez vous la capacité des
opérateurs alternatifs qui seraient
candidats à la reprise de ces liaisons
de ces 23 liaisons de pouvoir disposer
de conducteurs rapidement pour assurer
ces liaisons dès lors qu'une part
significative d'entre eux serait repris
par l'activité voyageur au sein de la
SNCF je vous remercie
si monsieur le Président donc alors bon
de mon vécu je
j'arrive je mets je mets aux manches fin
19 début 20 quand même la construction
est déjà faite bon et donc ça tombe
d'éléments je suis déjà dans
l'application dans les éléments de
conception et de discussion à mon je les
ai pas forcément vécus pour moi j'ai
l'impression que c'est indépendant la
dette la reprise de Dead de 35 milliards
et les 5300 indépendants enfin en tout
cas j'ai jamais vu entendu un lien entre
les deux donc
pour moi la dette réseau la reprise de
35 milliards d'être réseau n'a jamais
fait d'ailleurs vraiment problème c'est
le réseau là on parle du réseau c'est
bien commun c'est un bien commun c'est
presque au fond c'est une régularisation
ça fait un moment que la Commission
trouvait bizarre la notion d'épics
réseau société commerciale qui peut
vivre de CPH et d'ailleurs elle
demandait est-ce que c'est d'être
comptabilisée comme une dette publique
oui voilà donc je pense ça fait au moins
que la Commission trouver le montage un
peu baroque et qu'elle souhaitait bon
c'est pour ça qu'on se sent ce qui s'est
passé sur le réseau
il va bien je veux dire bon voilà donc
la reprise de 35 milliards est une
décision de l'actionnaire etc qui
soulage d'autant SNCF réseau ce qui lui
permet d'investir davantage dans la
régénération bon j'ai pas entendu de
critique en droit en droit de la
concurrence sur ce sujet là ne serait-ce
parce que n'est pas dans l'univers de la
concurrence le 5-3 la dette alors ça ça
c'est alors on se rappelle le
raisonnement de
bon sens moi parce que moi j'ai besoin
de le dire en français comprend cible
par mois parce que au fond ce que
reproche la commission c'est la durée
c'est le 2007 2019 quoi en gros ça
aurait durer un an ou deux ou trois de
dire bon ok vous soutenez une une c'est
pas une filiale à l'époque mais enfin
une division en perte ok mais un truc
qui structurellement en perte de 2007
qu'il a qui était avant d'ailleurs 2017
ça ça fait long en fait vous avez faussé
le marché parce que vous avez soutenu
une manière artificielle une société qui
s'il avait pas été soutenue par vous et
qu'est-ce qu'elle aurait pu faire ou
elle a augmenté ses prix parce que les
coûts étaient pourquoi les températures
parce que ce qu'elle gagne et est
inférieur à ce que ça coûte bon donc
pour essayer de rattraper les coups
alors on ne s'est pris et on voit ce que
ça donne ou les clients suivent ça va
bien oui suivent pas ils vont chez les
concurrents mais en tout cas ça se
clarifie
voilà ou alors elle arrête elle arrête
donc au fond je pense que c'est la c'est
le fait que dans la durée cette
situation n'est jamais été remplie il y
a quelques épisodes au milieu mais enfin
voilà je pense que le fait que ce ce
problème ce soit étalé dans la durée
je pense que c'est ça fondamentalement
qui qui pose problème à la à la
Commission
et le montant c'est un calcul donc voilà
et je le redis enfin c'est important
je pense que l'État français
à l'occasion de la de la de la
constitution de nouvelles SNCF à s'est
retrouvé avec cette dette bon a fait le
choix de la loger dans sa tête la
communiquer à la commission
pensant que peut-être ce montage allait
suffire voilà je le redis il y a pas eu
de retour sans explicite de la
commission c'est-à-dire que le covid est
arrivé assez vite donc il y a un peu
aussi occulté
peut-être tout l'ensemble de ces
dossiers qui ont été suspendus voilà et
quand cancer parti ben on a vu que la
Commission malheureusement est tombée du
mauvais côté quoi bon
je suis pas au courant de refaire donc
je suis président je préfère pas
inventer je suis pas au courant donc je
je peux pas vous répondre à la question
oui je pense que vous avez tout à fait
compris mon alors je dis ça parce que
j'étais j'ai d'abord dans ma carrière
longue j'étais pas dans le fret mais
j'étais quand même à la SNCF donc je
voyais bien ce qui s'est passé et je
voyais bien moi j'étais au Comex de la
SNCF à partir de 2006 donc quand même
j'ai côtoyé les instances de direction
de de de
la SNCF à l'époque n'y avait oui il y
avait FF déjà mais enfin il y avait la
grande SNCF donc je voyais bien je
voyais bien les soucis que cette
division et cette activité pouvaient
poser aux dirigeants concernés
au fond au fond les les collègues
étaient en charge je mettais en charge
de transport public donc mes collègues
étaient en charge du fret ils étaient un
peu là-dessus ils voyaient bien que ces
éléments ces inébollurs comment dire en
anglais c'est c'est ces éléments
indispensables absolument nécessaires à
l'activité qui était un accès en
capacité à des sillons de qualité d'un
côté et deuxièmement soutien wagon isolé
parce que tout seul il s'en sortait pas
ces éléments là ils étaient déjà là donc
au fond je pense que
oui je pense que et troisièmement le
troisième élément qui était
le surcoût du T2 etc fait c'est surcoût
un peu
organique de Frat SNCF était aussi sur
la table tout ça était sur la table et
je pense que oui c'est bien ça à moi à
mon avis les causes profondes et c'est
vrai que par rapport à ça il y a pas une
politique publique en face de ça sur ces
trois éléments là stratégie capacitaire
du réseau d'un côté être structuré avant
avant pendant là voilà donc assez
période là voilà donc bon donc je je
pense que je confirme ce que vous dites
et c'est vrai là encore pour être précis
alors peut-être dans le dans le choc du
plan de relance faire le choc de la
crise covid et donc du plan de relance
oui c'est vrai que là pour la première
fois alors c'est vrai qu'au même moment
on a aussi ce qui est pas indifférent on
a un secteur qui se qui se il y a une
association qui n'existait qui avait
jamais existé entre tous les opérateurs
de prêter SNCF 4F ou d'ailleurs la SNCF
ne cherche pas à prendre le lit du tout
elle est partie prenante cette
association sans vouloir surtout pas
j'allais dire même surtout pas la
diriger c'est pour l'intérêt du secteur
en général que les gens se regroupent et
au fond c'est ce qui est formule ils
disent ils redisent ces vérités
profondes il faut nous aider sinon on
s'en sort pas par les suivants en
exploitation au secteur et deuxièmement
il faut un programme volontariste sur
les infrastructures donc c'est c'est
comme dans le plan de relance il y a on
voit l'appareil les deux dans le plan de
relance il y a un volet pour la première
fois historique en France 170 millions
d'euros pour le secteur qui font quand
même du bien et qui explique les
résultats corrects ou plus corrects des
de tout le secteur d'ailleurs à partir
de là et puis dans le dans les quatre
pinards et quelques euros sur les
infrastructures dans le plan de relance
il y a on commence à avoir des éléments
fléchés avec par exemple Miramas qui a
été refait le triage de Miramas qui a
été refait en prenant une partie de ses
fonds donc on commence à avoir des actes
concrets qui montrent qu'on va enfin
dans le bon sens on aide le secteur
intern et on met de l'argent sur les
infrastructures pour qu'ils disposent
des outils de travail des équipements
dont il a besoin voilà donc ça c'est
quand même effectivement un point
d'inflexion important ce qui fait que le
gère le coup de barre il est mis mais
maintenant il faut le faut le tenir il
faut l'amplifier dans la durée on sait
ce qu'il faut faire on a commencé à le
faire il faut il faut poursuivre sur le
sur le social bon d'abord on se le redit
c'est
il y a une pierre que ça pour nageur ils
ont rien demandé les agents les agents
voilà ils subissent complètement la
situation en plus faut peut-être que les
deux patrons du frais de l'ont fait
passer ils aiment leur métier ils aiment
le fret ils sont pas là par hasard et on
dit souvent qu'il y a une famille un peu
des fraiseux les gens du fret ils sont
un peu à part ils ont un métier
particulier ils sont très très impliqués
dans cette cause faire circuler les
trains de marchandises ils savent très
bien que c'est de l'économie il y a les
entreprises derrière qui attendent les
marchandises qui sont dans leur train
ils sont très très impliqués là-dessus
et puis conducteur d'un train de
marchandises c'est pas tout à fait
conducteur en train de voyager c'est du
long parcours long parcourt c'est un peu
comme voilà c'est c'est ils partent pour
longtemps ils ont quasiment tout le
temps des découcher mais j'allais dire
quelque part ils aiment bien ça ils ont
une responsabilité sur leur train c'est
des gens très responsables qui ont ils
sont seuls sur locomotive ils mettent
leur locomotive sur des wagons dans un
triage ils partent pour plusieurs
centaines de kilomètres ils font le
relais avec un autre conducteur il
conduisent la nuit beaucoup la nuit et
on a affaire à une catégorie de
conducteurs qui aime bien ce métier là
qui est un métier spécifique donc ils
sont attachés leur métier en plus ils
sont attachés à l'entreprise sont
attachés au secteur ils sont attaché à
leur métier bon donc ils ont rien
demandé ils sont à Perpignan où ils sont
à Woippy et tout à coup par moment
l'ordi ah va falloir arrêter de voir
arrêter votre activité choc violent et
dans un délai assez rapide bon le
principe c'est qu'ils aient quelque
chose bon
après je sais bien que dans les dans les
éléments dans la lettre que j'ai reçu du
ministre qui me dit voilà ce qu'il faut
mettre en place effectivement pour
éviter le report modal
comme il faut prévenir la situation dans
laquelle ou le le nouvel entrant qui
serait prêt à prendre le trafic pas
forcément la locomotive et le conducteur
une locomotive c'est matériel c'est pas
très compliqué à transférer conducteur
c'est pas pareil voilà donc il y a dans
l'idée qu'on serait peut-être amené à
prêter ou faire des prestations de
traction pour le nouvel entrant le temps
que il est le temps d'acheter une
locomotive ou la louer ou recruter des
conducteurs c'est c'est l'élément
effectivement qui fait partie du paysage
mais ça c'est sur la base du volontariat
des conducteurs on forcera pas les
conducteurs il a un contrat de travail
SNCF voilà alors oui il est convaincu il
a envie de faire ce métier etc bon
pourquoi pas mais moi je préjugue pas de
la décision des conducteurs dans ce cas
là c'est un conducteur faisait le choix
de rester à la SNCF plutôt que de
prester pour nous pour
un nouveau un nouveau concurrent il est
de mon devoir de trouver des solutions
voilà les solutions les plus évidentes
c'est les TER c'est la charge de travail
de conduite alors c'est pas la même
charge de travail mais en fait ça n'est
une il reste dans leur métier de
conducteur il reste dans le service
public on essaie de le retrouver quelque
chose de plus à domicile possible le
plus proche possible de chez eux et même
je crois mais je sais pas si Frédéric on
vous l'a dit ou Jérôme Le borne on
pourrait même avoir le principe que s'il
souhaite vraiment un jour revenir au
Fred parce qu'ils adorent ce métier en
fait SNCF dans ce cas là on peut dire
ben vous êtes sur liste d'attente quoi
dès qu'on a besoin un nouveau de
conducteur on vous a pas oublié quoi si
vraiment c'est votre envie de piloter
des trains des locomotives de fret on
vous a pas oublié vous pouvez revenir
voilà
merci merci monsieur le Président je
pense que dans les questions qui vous
seront formulées on aura l'occasion de
revenir sur la manière dont concrètement
les choses se passeront pour les
salariés de Frat SNCF ce qu'il s'agit
d'un droit d'options comme on peut le
voir ailleurs de la manière dont ils
devront se positionner ou se ramener à
se positionner sur le choix de leur
activité à venir monsieur le rapporteur
vous avez la parole
si monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Directeur
merci de votre contribution
vous dites
réforme 2018
nous avions l'espoir d'avoir progressé
vis-à-vis de Bruxelles
d'ailleurs en répondant en lointain écho
à
la corde 2005
et bien à la constitution d'une SA
puisque dans la corde 2005 avec la
Commission européenne
la SA est explicitement cité
avez-vous pas
le sentiment
[Musique]
que finalement
on bâti il est bâti en 2018
un passage de lipidique et ça sur un
profond malentendu diront certains ou
sur une absence de commentaires diront
d'autres de part et d'autre puisque vous
dites bien effectivement que
la Commission ne donne pas son avis sur
voilà en gros
il semblerait que personne valide
le bien fondé d'une transformation de
l'épique en SA
qui objectivement revient dans la
décision de 2023 autour du moi dans les
commentaires 2023 de la Commission
européenne comme pourtant
naissance
d'une société non viable avec
l'extraction de la dette
donc là il y a il y a une ambiguïté
majeure sur lequel il y a quelques et
quelques interrogations
qui qui nous interpelle ça c'est ma
première observation et question en même
temps deuxième aspect vous
vous avez visiblement reçu de l'exécutif
entre 2019 et 2022
la commande politique
et bien de
ne pas faire de la situation de sa
frette SNCF
un dossier d'obligation
[Musique]
est-ce que vous pouvez nous confirmer
cette commande politique que vous n'avez
pas eu de 2019 à 2022
donc sous l'autorité des deux premiers
ministres que j'ai cités mais aussi sous
l'autorité des deux
ministres des Transports
afférents savoir madame borne et
Monsieur Dubarry
monsieur rapporteur donc sur le sur le
premier point oui je vais vous le dites
avec vos mots mais est-ce que c'est
malentendu en tout cas
je ne doute pas que la conviction de de
l'État français et avec les dirigeants
de la SNCF de l'époque était que le
mouvement envers la SAS le
la reconnaissance de la déesse je veux
dire et sa localisation transparente
des comprévisionnels dans le verre qui
s'est quand même avéré
était des éléments de nature à améliorer
le dossier et en tout cas permet de la
poursuivre des discussions en essayant
de trouver une voie une voie de sortie à
l'amiable je vais dire bon
donc je la commission je n'ayant donné
aucun avis forcément on pouvait pas
savoir ce qu'elle pensait
et je pense que pour le d'ailleurs c'est
l'aimant et on voit au deuxième
du coup la parenthèse covid est en passé
quand les discussions reprennent
effectivement
[Musique]
la position du ministre Jedi et de
valider par le Premier ministre c'est de
c'est la Commission durciton on commence
à durcir le ton c'est de refuser toute
toute perspective de discontinuité
reprenant les arguments juridiques qui
avaient été défendu jusqu'à lors un
investissement avisé l'intérêt général
de mise en perspective dans le cadre du
Green Deal et puis des éléments nouveaux
des évolutions de type transition
écologique etc voilà donc il y avait
droit d'environnement donc il y avait un
certain nombre d'éléments
juridico-politique mis en avant pour
justifier une position
de refus effectivement d'envisager de
partir sur une discontinuité
et l'exécutif semblait sembler confiance
dans sa capacité à tenir cette ligne moi
c'est ce qui nous disait quand on leur
posait la question
et
bon on sait que le changement de
gouvernement intervient à l'été 22 donc
et à l'automne mais mais voilà je suis
factuel
on sent on sent une
durcissement de la position de la
Commission qui qui
discussions je passe comment les
qualifier ouvertes ou de travail ou
exploratoire ou changer d'attitude et on
arrive à une quasi conclusion donc
change de police de posture et exprime
une quasi conviction que il y a en
poursuivi leurs travaux d'investigation
leur analyse juridique etc on a bien
fait à une éniga et donc comment ça
mettre à mettre sur la table la
perspective d'une ouverture de procédure
voilà je sais pas quand c'est exactement
c'est à l'automne
voilà après moi je je je ne sais pas
exactement quelle est la réaction de
l'exécutif à partir de ce changement de
posture bon le fait suivant c'est cette
ouverture de procédure qui change la
donne
très bien on a une question de Monsieur
Thomas porte monsieur le député de
Seine-Saint-Denis vous avez la parole
puis ensuite on aura même clapot madame
Arrighi monsieur censure madame Ferrer
monsieur député merci monsieur le
Président Monsieur le Président
j'ai effectivement plusieurs questions
d'abord je salue vos propos où il vous
avait dit que finalement l'ouverture à
la concurrence n'avait pas été le remède
magique puisque on a entendu un certain
intervenants qui nous ont dit que
l'ouverture à la concurrence a été
quelque chose de formidable et on nous
l'avait vendu comme le remède miracle
elle est réglé le problème du fret on
voit que ce n'est pas le cas aujourd'hui
donc c'est quand même une parole qui
fait du bien entendre et je tenais à le
dire et vous avez aussi dans vos propos
plaider pour une politique publique
ambitieuse sur le fret de ferroviaire et
une aide de l'État à destination de fret
SNCF
et vous avez aussi exprimé le sentiment
convaincu que le Fred ferroviaire public
domaine allait prendre une part
importante parce que c'était un outil
indispensable de la transition
écologique je crois qu'on le partage
tous ici moi j'ai plusieurs questions
sur ce sujet là
nous nous interrogeons sur comment avoir
un opérateur public qui soit demain en
capacité de relever le défi de
transporter plus de marchandises sur le
rail pour diminuer la part modale sur la
route avec un opérateur public qui va
être diminué puisqu'il va perdre quand
même 10% de ses effectifs un certain
nombre de conducteurs
il a écrit dans le fameux plan de
discontinuité que il sera impossible de
candidater pendant 10 ans notamment sur
le transport combiné qui est quand même
l'activité la plus rentable aujourd'hui
donc comment concilier ces deux
problèmes
l'autre sujet c'est la SNCF possède un
son simple plusieurs filiales
aujourd'hui de fret donc s'il y a déjà
quasiment une concurrence en interne sur
le sujet du fret pourquoi on n'a pas une
seule entreprise de Fred SNCF public et
pas plusieurs filiales de frais et SNCF
au sein de la même entreprise publique
ensuite j'aimerais avoir votre avis sur
on parle beaucoup de la relance du fret
mais il y a pas aussi la une dichotomie
avec ce qui s'est passé ces dernières
années puisque il y a eu quand même la
vente de arméva il y a eu la vente de
Hakim qui sont quand même des
locomotives et des wagons qui étaient
utiles pour lancer le frais de
ferroviaire et le groupe public c'est
délesté d'un certain nombre d'outils qui
étaient intéressants pour relancer le
frais de ferroviaire et enfin dernière
question j'en aurais sûrement d'autres
après elle est sur la question du
transfert des salariés et de l'avenir
des 10% de cheminots qui aujourd'hui
sont menacés
qu'en est-il si il n'y a pas 10% de
personnes qui aujourd'hui sur la base du
volontariat décide
de partir de Frat SNCF comment ça va se
passer pour eux même si j'ai entendu le
fait qu'il y avait une possibilité de
les transférer conducteur fret à TER
vous l'avez souligné vous-même c'est pas
le même métier c'est pas le même zone
géographique parfois même s'il peut y
avoir des facilités donc quel est
véritablement le plan pour ces cheminots
qui vous l'avez dit ont permis au pays
de tenir debout pendant le covid ça fait
15 ans qui subissent restructuration sur
restructuration avec le sentiment d'être
abandonné parfois par le groupe public
ferroviaire et d'être laissé de côté
avec des fermetures de triage des
suppressions de poste c'était le parent
pauvre le fret depuis quelques années à
la SNCF donc comment ça va se passer
pour ces 10% de salariés qui aujourd'hui
ont une épée au-dessus de la tête qui le
vivent très mal qui sont dans un
quotidien qui est très douloureux merci
juste une précision pour compléter ce
que vous disiez c'est que
finalement vous parliez des aides d'État
à fêter SNCF c'est justement l'objet des
êtres publiques de ce que regarde la
Commission européenne ce qui a dit
Jean-Pierre pernando sauf si je l'ai mal
compris c'est que le niveau de ses
d'État a fortement cru ces dernières
années et ça c'est des chiffres et que
la différence c'est qu'elle s'adresse
maintenant à l'activité Fred c'est ça la
grosse différence monsieur le président
oui alors le comment on fait pour pour
on va parler du secteur d'abord il fait
à chaque fois il faut je pense qu'il
faut dissocier le secteur de
l'entreprise alors les deux sont
importants parce que moi je suis patron
de l'entreprise mais l'entreprise dans
un secteur si le secteur va bien elle
ira mieux que les secteurs va mal et ça
serait étonnant qu'elle aille bien
qu'elle aille bien quoi donc c'est quand
même lié le secteur le secteur c'est
c'est la transition écologique l'enjeu
oui il faut un plan ambitieux concret
plus réelle parce que ça va pas se
déformer en un an ou deux il faut une
vraie volonté de s'installer dans la
durée pour créer les conditions
que des clients des entreprises
choisissent davantage le wagon les
trains pour transporter la marchandise
parce qu'on va pas les forcer mais il
faut créer les conditions de qualité de
coûts de service qui font que les
entreprises vont faire vont basculer de
aujourd'hui la route en gros vers le
train voilà c'est ça qui est essentiel
quand on tire cette pelote la production
du service et bien il faut des sillons
de qualité les sillons c'est les
horaires c'est le temps de parcours si
il y a pas des si on aurait ferroviaire
de qualité les trains vont arriver trop
tard ils seront pas au bons horaires ils
vont mettre trois jours à arriver alors
que le camion il aura fait en une
demi-journée voilà ça c'est la-bas et le
sillon c'est le réseau les capacités du
réseau voilà le réseau parfois il est
saturé il a mauvais état donc la mère
des batailles pour le fret comme pour le
voyageur d'ailleurs c'est le réseau donc
il faut mettre de l'argent dans le
réseau j'ai entendu le gouvernement dire
4 milliards d'ici 2032 je crois avec 2
milliards d'ici 2027 voilà il faut le
réseau
lever tous les goulots étranglement à
Angers les voix les voix de service
aussi pas oublier les water les triages
qui sont mauvais état ce qu'on a fait à
Miramas il faut le faire sur tous les
trois autres grandes triages français
voilà donc ça c'est important et plus il
y aura de la capacité plus on pourra
augmenter les traits entre les triages
aussi enfin tout se tient faut vraiment
renverser cette spirale en mettant de
l'argent dans le réseau ferroviaire pour
qu'on puisse produire en qualité plus de
transport de fret ça ça profitera tout
le secteur Fred SNCF comme concurrents
enfin il faut le faire c'est très
important
deuxièmement il faut inciter peut-être
des entreprises à y aller quoi une fois
que les conditions matérielles sont
créées il faut inciter il y a deux
manières d'inciter c'est où on rend
moins cher le transport de fret par les
aides les aides du gouvernement vers le
secteur bon c'est la choix qui a été
choisi on sait que d'autres pays ont
rajouté de la fiscalité sur le sur le
camion de la taxe sur le on a failli
faire avec les contacts on était à ça de
le faire il y avait les portiques il y
avait les portiques
ils y sont toujours bon voilà donc on
sait très bien qu'à partir du moment
c'est raté c'est compliqué d'y revenir
mais quand même mais quand même
l'Allemagne il y a je crois est en train
de d'avoir des des surpéages pour les
pour les poids lourds sur ces autoroutes
bon voilà donc c'est pas voilà après
c'est un choix politique on le fait on
le fait pas ces murs c'est pas mûr voilà
mais mais bon on voit bien qu'il y a
qu'il peut y aussi y avoir des
interventions de l'État par la fiscalité
positive ou moins pour corriger
finalement le et amplifier le report
modal voilà ça il faut le faire pour le
secteur pour l'entreprise c'est
d'ailleurs je vais répondre avec la
deuxième question je pense que il faut
moi je je pense l'entreprise fait SNCF
mais je pense tout le pôle ferroviaire
du groupe SNCF et ça s'oppose pas et
peut-être d'ailleurs que là aussi il y
aura des convergences entre entre tous
ces éléments
vous avez raison qu'au départ l'histoire
elle est différente il y a Fret SNCF
c'est l'héritière de l'activité Fred de
la SNCF comme dirait l'autre voilà par
contre les quatre trains c'est une
succession de petites filiales qui ont
été rachetées souvent d'ailleurs en
Espagne en Italie en Allemagne et puis
il y avait l'ancien avait félic est
devenu Catherine France qui est qui est
en groupe SSD depuis longtemps et tout
ça a été regroupé sur Captain au fond
sans l'avoir souhaité mais je vous dis
on s'adapte aux circonstances on est en
train de catégoriser au sein de
l'ensemble en disant mais l'ancien fait
SNCF il va se mettre sur le ce qu'on
appelle le mutualiser on roule triage et
il est très intertriage et les desserts
qui vont avec donc c'est le wagon isolé
c'est les coupons il va se mettre là
dessus et et comme on est banni pendant
10 ans toute manière on n'a pas le choix
les quatre trains alors ils ont banni
trois ans quand même et sur les 23 flux
seulement pas sur les autres encore faut
préciser bon les 23 flux ben si c'est 3
ans c'est 3 ans mais il y a les autres
il y a d'autres flux qui peuvent
apparaître ou qu'après il peut se
présenter voilà donc je pense que on
peut tout à fait
enclencher une une politique de
développement sur l'ancien Fret SNCF et
le donc le wagon isolé dès lors que on a
les aides on a les investissements on
est les entreprises amener des petites
quantités et plus que du train entier et
ça on pense qu'un potentiel important
vraiment important il y a des régions
qui ont pas été à nous aider là-dessus
enfin on sent que ça bouge en France
là-dessus et puis deuxièmement sur les
les flux très entiers voilà pendant 10
ans on prêtait ses élèves peu plus joués
on a les captains qui peuvent quand même
à part les 23 flux pendant trois ans qui
peuvent se battre sur ce secteur voilà
donc je pense qu'on peut tout à fait
avoir cette vision de de d'expansion et
de développement herméva et akem
là on revient dans le plan de relance le
plan
en amont la crise covid la vraie crise
covid là on l'a on l'a bien ça c'est pas
vu ça c'est pas vu parce que l'État nous
a aidé il faut être honnête c'est une
cata pour la SNCF ça n'était jamais
arrivé moi je l'ai vécu là pour le coup
j'y étais les TGV étaient à l'arrêt les
TGV étaient à l'arrêt on avait puisque
on se souvient plus les déplacements
interagiront étaient interdits pour des
raisons sanitaires dans le gouvernement
nous a dit vous arrêtez les TGV
on en tenait je crois un aller-retour
par jour pour des raisons impérieuses au
cas où les gens avaient absolument
besoin de bouger sur Bordeaux etc
la flotte TGV à l'arrêt imaginez les
conséquences économiques à le TGV c'est
quand même le poumon économique de
l'entreprise mais ce poumon il était
arrêté bon
là les euros il défilent ils rentrent
pas dans les caisses je redis d'ailleurs
bon danseurs que le en chiffre
d'affaires j'ai le chiffre en tête sur
la période du covid 21-22 enfin 21 début
22 10 milliards d'euros en moins 10
milliards d'euros en moins
bon ça fait beaucoup d'argent
le gouvernement
il a fait son travail d'actionnaire
quand vous avez une énorme espèce de oui
on est on est une filiale de l'État
ouais on est à 100% etc quand vous avez
une filiale qui est en grande difficulté
mais il faut l'aider il nous a aidé il
nous a aidé il a fait le choix de mettre
le paquet sur l'infrastructure pour nous
permettre de poursuivre cet effort de
régénération qui est qui était
consubstantiel de la réforme 2018 dont
l'essentiel du plan de relance de 4
milliards et demi de mémoire c'est je
l'ai dit tout à l'heure pour poursuivre
l'effort d'origination sur le réseau
donc ils sont donnés en réseau en
augmentation de capital donner un réseau
et il y a les traits de nuit pour
relancer les trains nus dans un petit
pouce au point de nuit qui qui sont en
train de renaître un peu en Europe et il
y a le fret pour la première fois c'est
sans un million d'euros c'est ça et un
peu d'accessibilité enfin tout ça on
peut le mettre dans le réseau voilà donc
ayant fait son travail d'actionnaire en
recapitalisant réseau bah il nous
demande de faire le travail de manager
en disant mais vous devez participer à
l'effort
pour éviter un endettement massif de
l'entreprise
ça c'est dit en termes pudique quand on
traduit concrètement ce que ça veut dire
ça veut dire c'est les actifs pour
réaliser de l'argent on vend des actifs
ça fait de l'argent qui rentre dans les
caisses et qui rend plus les finances de
la SNCF quoi c'est ça que ça veut dire
bon on a regardé
il nous est apparu qu'on avait deux
filiales qui n'étaient pas stratégiques
dont on pouvait se passer
elle marchait bien c'était les filiales
qui qui ça c'est vraiment des choix que
vous faites quand ça va mal c'est pas
des choix que vous faites là encore
quand ça va bien
elle gagne bien leur vie c'était parce
qu'ils étaient la gestion d'actifs
wagons d'un côté avec arméa locomotive
de l'autre avec akem et donc elle valait
de l'argent sur le marché elle va aller
de l'argent dans les a vendus
on en a tiré 4 milliards de ces deux
sessions voilà c'est 4 milliards là pour
le coup qui sont rentrés dans les
caisses qui ont permis de désendetter à
hauteur de cadillère la dette de la SNCF
qui s'était creusée c'est au lieu de se
réduire ce qui était prévu dans la
réforme elle s'était aggravée à cause du
covid voilà on a amené 4 milliards pour
réduire l'impact sur la dette voilà
c'est une décision de la nature
d'équilibre d'équilibre financier sur
deux éléments dont on pensait qu'ils
étaient pas absolument stratégique en
terme de propriété pour le groupe
puisqu'on pouvait continuer à accéder au
service de location vous transformez une
propriété en location vous louez les
wagons vous louez les rouleaux les
locomotives sur les salariés bon je
pense qu'il y a encore la place à
clarification peut-être que tout est pas
encore parfaitement ciselé et d'un
dialogue social d'ailleurs je pense que
c'est un des sujets qui va qui va être
traité discuté donc c'est un peu des
principes et des options que je vais
vous donner j'en avais pas encore à
ajuster ne serait-ce que ils feront
discuter
il faudra certainement discuter moi je
pense qu'il y a deux principes qu'il va
falloir concilier
le premier principe c'est quand même la
liberté des salariés je pense que c'est
peut-être le principe numéro 1 salarié
il faut qu'il puisse décider de son sort
et je le redis il est salarié de la SNCF
du groupe SNCF voilà il a un contrat de
travail avec la SNCF donc SNCF laissera
pas tomber ça c'est ce que je redis
d'abord
après l'autre principe c'est que
effectivement ça serait bien que soit
créé les conditions qui est pas de
report modal pour pas qu'il y ait de
report modal faut que c'est très
intransféré ça dépend quelle vitesse à
quadrine etc c'est pour ça qu'il y a pas
mal d'inconnu encore dans le dans le
sujet qu'on est des conducteurs de train
en face parce que si on n'a pas des
conducteurs de train en face forcément
on va avoir un problème bon
en particulier pour le combiner le
combiné c'est ce qui repart ressort par
le plus vite à la route parce que par
nature déjà c'est un transport mixte
souvent transporté il a une part
routière donc si vous avez pu le train
ben le camion qui a le container
derrière il va continuer quoi voilà donc
le le type de trafic le plus facile
quelque part à repartir à la route c'est
combiné donc sur le combiné oui il faut
souhaiter qu'on trouve des conducteurs
voilà là encore c'est un choix
individuel ce choix personnel des
premières discussions engagées j'ai cru
comprendre qu'il y avait des conduits
alors il resteront SNCF attention il
resteront SNCF mais dans le cas d'une
prestation globale traction à la fois le
conducteur et la machine qu'on pourrait
vendre à un nouvel entrant
on peut penser que certains conducteurs
pourraient l'accepter pendant 6 mois 12
mois c'est pas très long voilà donc
cette situation là doit être clarifié
encore dans ces mécanismes et et encore
plus dans ses volumes ça je pense que et
dans son planning voilà il y a encore
pas mal d'inconnu autour du point que
vous soulevez et une partie de ces
questions donnant lieu un dialogue
social intense dans l'entreprise entre
la direction de fret les ressources
syndicales et les agents eux-mêmes
donc on a une question de Madame
Mireille clapot la députée du Rhône
la Drôme excuse-moi je pensais tellement
au fleuve et au circulation sur les deux
rives que je suis remonter un peu au
nord de Valence
donc merci à Monsieur le Président de la
Commission monsieur le rapporteur chers
collègues alors monsieur le Président
Directeur Général merci de votre
intervention je peux vous dire que nous
sommes nombreux déjà ici mais au-delà à
partager votre ambition de relancer le
fret ferroviaire donc comme ça a été dit
en deux fois je suis député de la Drôme
j'ai trois points plusieurs intervenants
ont souligné c'est un point que je
partage que c'est vraiment par la
qualité de service
certes le prix certes la maîtriser
risque mais surtout la qualité de
service qui va déterminer les chargeurs
à choisir un mode de transport plutôt
qu'un autre donc vous l'avez dit aussi
et je repose une question pour avoir
votre point de vue c'est comment est-ce
que
Fred SNCF peut investir mais pas que
dans des infrastructures pas que dans du
matériel aussi dans du numérique dans
des ressources humaines commerciales et
d'exploitation de la gestion de la
relation client
un deuxième point vous avez dit que les
travaux sur les lignes sont fait la nuit
je voulais juste c'est désolé pour les
collègues qui ont déjà entendu vous dire
que donc on va aller du Rhône puisque
j'habite on va aller du Rhône j'entends
les trains passés en rive gauche qui
sont censés être que pour les voyageurs
et en rive droite qui sont censés dédiés
au frais
si les travaux se faisaient comme ils
doivent se faire sur la voie dédiée au
fret il y aurait moins de train de fret
qui passent la nuit au cœur de la ville
y compris avec des matières dangereuses
donc ça fait partie des mystères et puis
j'ai un troisième point alors je vais
mettre beaucoup de guillemets il fut un
temps mais il y a très très longtemps
bien sûr ou une rumeur circulait à la
SNCF et anonymement en dehors
il se disait que les transports de
voyageurs étaient profitables mais qu'à
la direction du fret c'était une grande
opacité voir une grande
et que donc il valait mieux sauvegarder
les profits issus de la branche
voyageurs et les réinvestir chez les
voyageurs ou dans des filiales mais
surtout pas réinvestir ces profits dans
Fred je ferme les guillemets bien sûr
j'ai aussi trouvé une anecdote assez
drôle là aussi sans doute de la de la
légende urbaine un ancien directeur de
fret SNCF dit un jour j'ai attribué dans
les tableaux horaires numéro de train de
passagers une circulation quotidienne de
fret le train est arrivé parfaitement à
l'heure pendant une semaine le temps que
les aiguilleurs découvrent qu'il ne
transportait pas de voyageurs
alors tout ça c'est de la légende que je
vais qualifier de créer aux et pas les
relayer néanmoins pour revenir à notre
sujet je voulais savoir si ces
événements qui sont difficiles comme
vous l'avez dit ne vont pas
paradoxalement entraîner une certaine
maîtrise des coûts une certaine
transparence puisque Fred SNCF sera
particulièrement observé dans la période
qui s'ouvre merci
merci beaucoup oui madame la député donc
oui quel était le service c'est ça vous
l'avez bien rappelé on est il faudra
convaincre les chargeurs de choisir le
train donc ces qualités de service
d'abord fiabilité bien sûr des horaires
pertinents des horaires à cheminement
information de l'état de lors de leur
trafic ouais où sont les marchandises à
quelle heure elles arrivent
un peu les coups quand même parce que
tout le monde regardait coup en ce
moment donc faut être compétitif en
matière de coût
voilà donc c'est et puis la relation
commerciale bien sûr c'est très
important de d'avoir un bonnes relations
de prospection et de fidélisation de la
clientèle c'est le cas on a des exemples
Arcelor par exemple vous dire la
relation est très bonne avec Arcelor et
RC Orphée le choix du ferroviaire et de
fret à SNCF en particulier donc on a on
a des exemples positifs bien sûr à
proposer il y a une autre argument je le
redis quand même je suis convaincu qu'il
va peser de plus en plus et le scope 3
on se le redit toutes les entreprises
vont devoir gérer leurs impacts sur
l'environnement 1 et 2 elles bon parce
qu'elles ont les leviers c'est comme
trois c'est plus compliqué par
définition mais elles sont amenées quand
même à être responsabilisés sur le scope
3 et pour verdir l'oscope 3 ben faire
moins de camions et plus de train ça
marche quoi donc on est aussi poussé par
ces par ces j'allais dire quasi
réglementations on fait ses obligations
qui sont en train d'arriver et je pense
que c'est une des explications du fait
qu'on est remonté notre part de marché
c'est à la fois que notre qualité de
service a dû s'amélioré nos coûts sont
plus ajustés mais aussi on a ce besoin
des entreprises de verdir tout leurs
approvisionnements donc là c'est une
opportunité pour le ferroviaire en
général les frites SNCF en particulier
les investissements vous avez raison
peut-être pour être très précis
l'infrastructure ça c'est réseau qui
doit investir sur l'Infra c'est pas le
l'opérateur Fred quel qu'il soit
qu'investit sur les froid en tant que
tel ça c'est pour ça qu'il faut aussi
que réseau reçoivent de l'argent de
quelque part de l'état des régions ou
pour faire les investissements
nécessaires pour le pour le réseau par
contre les autres postes vous avez
raison matériel roulant beaucoup les
locomotives on sait que Fred SNCF va
avoir besoin de de d'acheter des
locomotives modernes dans la dans
l'avenir donc ça c'est important donc
c'est aussi il faut qu'il dégage assez
d'argent par son évida pour des
capacités d'autofinancement de ces
investissements notamment en locomotive
puisque les wagons en gros maintenant
sont loués le numérique bien sûr tout
est numérique tout est digital il y a
déjà des choses qui sont faites mais il
faudra les poursuivre et la relation
commerciale vous avez raison j'en parle
souvent avec souvent j'en parle avec
Frédéric Delorme et Jérôme Leborgne il
faut que Fred SNCF se réhabituent à
aller chercher des clients ils avaient
peut-être au cours des décennies un peu
de d'érosion de leur activité un peu
baisser la tête j'allais dire il faut la
relever il faut absolument avoir à être
avoir une attitude prospection sur le
sur le sur les entreprises et d'aller
chercher des clients nouveaux très
importants et on peut le faire d'autant
plus d'autant plus je rappelle le
business model de du ce que j'appelle le
transport mutualisé c'est une économie
de coût fixe vous avez les triages qui
tournent qui est des wagons qui n'est
pas vous avez des traits inter triages
plus ils vont être remplis plus et plus
c'est efficace avec un point mort
quelque part donc il est très important
d'aller chercher des marchandises pour
saturer les capacités d'emporte des
trains voilà donc là pour le coup
l'action commerciale elle est décisive
pour passer d'une situation compliquée à
une situation dans le verre voilà c'est
très important d'avoir cette volonté
commerciale il y a aussi un enjeu de de
d'équilibre économique
bon sur le sur les travaux qui seront
déroulent surtout la nuit des rive
gauche rive droite il y a un peu de
voyageurs qui revient vers la droite
soit aussi d'ailleurs je crois savoir un
petit peu voilà pas beaucoup mais un peu
voilà donc faudra trouver des équilibres
c'est clair elle a encore
l'idéal ça serait qui est un peu plus de
place peut-être soit pour les travaux de
jour qui laisseraient toute la place la
nuit soit pour les pour les trains de
frites un peu de veau etc ça veut dire
qu'il y aura en terme de stratégie
capacitaire du réseau il y aura des des
équilibres à trouver peut-être un peu
nouveau un peu plus favorable au fret et
donc quelque part un peu moins favorable
à voyager là encore il faudra faut
assumer les décisions qui sont okront
être prises tout ça avec discussion
concertation etc bien évidemment mais
mais c'est une des conditions si on veut
que le fait de se développe c'est une un
accès capacitaire plus facile plus
fluide au réseau
bon les rumeurs sont les rumeurs je les
commande pas
sur les sur la maîtrise des coûts je
vais vous dire c'est déjà fait quand
même
n'imaginez pas que que que mes collègues
de fret et ses élèves ne gèrent pas bien
leur boutique ils gèrent très bien leur
boutique et c'est pas nouveau
si ils sont dans le verre depuis deux
ans c'est que la boutique était très
bien gérée à la fois côté recette comme
côté coup avec des des ce qu'on appelle
pudiquement des plantes performance
c'est à dire des plans des plans
d'ajustements des coûts importants qui
sont en place
et qui ont été je le redis d'ailleurs
acceptés par les personnels qui ont joué
le jeu depuis des années
bon il est certain que que le que la
situation la situation nouvelle ne
pourra conduire qu'à qu'à amplifier ses
efforts mais ils existent déjà soyez
sûrs que prêter SNCF fait des efforts de
gestion serrés pour créer les conditions
de l'équilibre d'abord et de
développement par la suite
merci monsieur le Président Madame la
Députée Christine Arrighi
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Président Mesdames Messieurs alors
monsieur le Président vous faites
remonter le déclin du fret aux années
70-80 sans que il y a une date précise
qui soit
marqué en réalité c'est le déclin de la
SNCF hormis évidemment les choix qui ont
été faits par rapport au tout TGV qui a
complètement phagocyté toutes les autres
capacités de la SNCF dans le cadre du
budget qui lui a été alloué de
développer et de maintenir un réseau
extrêmement riche et extrêmement dense
que ce soit des lignes train de nuit que
ce soit le fret que ce soit le desserte
fine et tout autre dispositifs en termes
de régénération et de modernisation bon
il se trouve que la prise de conscience
actuelle par rapport au réchauffement
climatique permet de mettre l'accent sur
le fait que le ferroviaire c'est le
moyen le plus décarboné pour transporter
des
majeur et des marchandises et donc que
peut-être
nous sommes à l'aube d'une grande
embellie pour le ferroviaire je dis bien
peut-être parce que en tant que
commissaire des finances et en tant que
rapporteur spécial du rapport rapporteur
du rapport spécial transport à la
commission des finances nous voyons et
nous auditionnons pas mal d'acteurs du
transport et des mobilités nous voyons
et nous entendons beaucoup de chiffres
annoncés et vous-même en donner mais
pour l'instant sans véritablement de
traduction dans les éléments comptables
de l'État ni même des collectivités
locales puisque les CPER sont en cours
de discussion et pour l'instant à ma
connaissance à part deux les autres ne
sont pas encore conclus donc de votre
point de vue d'abord me dire ce dont
vous êtes sûr financièrement au niveau
du fret
si vous pouviez aller au-delà de la
question du fret ça serait intéressant
mais en tout cas au niveau du fret donc
vous êtes sûr financièrement ensuite
nous dire si dans ce dispositif
maintenant concurrentiel est-ce que vous
pensez que le fret pourra unique devenir
entre guillemets concurrentiel par son
attractivité au regard uniquement de
l'attractivité enfin de la contrainte du
score 3 ou vous pensez que
nécessairement il faudra s'orienter ou
se réorienter plus exactement sur
quelque chose qui s'appelait l'écotaxe
que l'on pourra appeler autrement qui
est fait partie d'un des grands
renoncements auxquels nous sommes nous
avons été confrontés et qui nous conduit
également à la situation d'aujourd'hui
et puis enfin sur les besoins d'aide
dont vous parlez en termes
d'infrastructures on ne pourra revenir
avec un fret conc présentiel à tout le
moins sur la question
décarbonation des transports que pour
autant nous ayons un réseau régénéré
donc si nous n'avons pas un réseau
régénéré vous avez parlé beaucoup des
sillons et bien évidemment que ce soit
pour le frais ou pour les voyageurs à
quel one de temps et selon qu'elle
financement vous estimez que ce réseau
sera régénéré ou serait régénéré pour
que le fret retrouve ses lettres de
noblesse et à tout le moins permettent
que il n'y ait pas un report de charge
sur le camion
merci madame la députée la question est
la question 3 se s'articule donc les
articuler
de quoi sommes-nous sûr on est on est
sûr de des 200 millions d'euros par an
d'aide au secteur ça je crois que ça a
été annoncé ferme donc là dessus moi je
considère que c'est sûr
bon oui pas voter mais ça je compte sur
vous là
les 170 millions par an la stratégie
nationale de fraiseur vierge eux ils ont
déjà été déposés ils sont dans le budget
2022 et dans le budget 2023 200 c'est
une augmentation je précise pérenniser
effectivement 2030
oui voilà alors modulo effectivement
dans ce cas là on est sûr de rien
puisque le budget n'étant pas voté la
réponse à votre question je ne suis sûr
de rien voilà bon voilà
bon mais j'ai beaucoup d'espoir bon
on peut redire les il y a quand même
quelques chiffres qui ont été articulés
donc on a le je pense légitime à les
citer en ayant quand même l'espoir qu'on
aille au bout ces fameux 200 millions
qui sont à 70 relevés à 200 qui a été
articulé d'ailleurs le ministre les a
présenté devant les syndicats quand les
a reçu sur le pour représenter le plan
discontinuité il a il a bien compris
qu'il fallait donner une perspective et
donc en tout cas il a il a annoncé ce
chiffre devant les organisations
syndicales qui ne forme quand même
d'engagement personnel qu'il a pu
prendre sur le sujet jusqu'en 2030 et à
ce stade à partir 2025 d'ailleurs on
discute si ça pouvait démarrer en 2024
ça serait pas plus mal mais mais
discussions sur le sur le sur le voilà
ou que ça puisse monter voilà qui est au
moins une première marche qui puisse
être accompli en 2024 il a aussi
articulé parce que la question de
l'infrastructure bien sûr est sur la
table 4 milliards d'euros d'ici 2032 je
crois avec 2 milliards à financer sur
2027 et ces deux miliens il a annoncé
que 900 millions d'ores et déjà été
financés ou en tout cas l'État s'engager
sur 900 millions déjà le reste étant à
trouver où aller près de l'État auprès
des collectivités etc donc il y a quand
même quelques chiffres qui sont qui sont
énoncés qui demandent à être validé vous
avez raison dans les dans les dans les
CPER dans le musée de l'État etc et on a
quelques chiffres qui sont articulés qui
sont présentés qui sont répétés
plusieurs fois donc voilà on est je suis
confiant dès lors que ces chiffres vont
connaître une réalité budgétaire
alors au-delà vous avez raison au-delà
au-delà il faut il faut il faut faire il
faut aller plus loin ça c'est on voit
bien que c'est la grosse difficulté à
les politiques publiques c'est
d'ailleurs du long terme
il s'est très très important de trouver
des diapositifs qui assurent sur le long
terme les investissements nécessaires
parce que le ferroviaire c'est ça c'est
le temps très long et au fond les
investissements qu'on fait aujourd'hui
ou dans les 10 ans qui viennent ils
auront des effets dans les 10 ans qui
suivent c'est c'est c'est ça la réalité
à l'inverse d'ailleurs si on ne les fait
pas ça se voit pas trop dans les années
qui viennent mais ça va se voir beaucoup
dans les 10 ans voilà dans les 15 ans 10
15 ans qui suivent c'est ça c'est ça qui
est particulier dans ces politiques
publiques c'est que elles amènent les
les élus ou les exécutifs ou les ou le
ou le Parlement apprendre des décisions
dans les effets la dépense est immédiate
c'est pour ça que c'est un peu un grand
politique publique la dépense est
immédiate mais les effets absolument
nécessaires se font sentir plus tard et
à l'inverse ne pas dépenser cet argent
on peut être une tentation mais dans ce
cas-là il n'exorablement on installe une
situation qui sera très difficile
dans les 10 15 ans qui viennent voilà
c'est c'est c'est c'est tout le tout le
tout tout l'enjeu tout l'enjeu qui a
autour de ces questions euh et là pour
le moment la rentrée de certitude je
n'en ai pas des certitudes je je sais à
peu près ce qu'il faudrait je suis pas
le seul d'ailleurs le COI s'est exprimé
avant moi et on a ici son président la
RT a fait une excellent rapport qui pose
elle aussi la thématique je crois de
manière très très lucide donc on on voit
un peu tout converge je pense le COI la
RT les propositions de la SNCF avaient
pu faire elle-même région de France
enfin on voit bien que il y a pas mal de
de je sais pas que d'entité d'entités
publiques dans ce pays qui ont qui est
la première ministre elle-même dans le
plan d'avenir des transports je pense
que tout est dit je veux dire tout est
dit maintenant effectivement on est
devant cette cet enjeu de financement
court moyen long terme qui fera que ça
se fait ou pas quoi finalement voilà
donc on a ce sujet devant nous
sur l'attractivité
moi je suis bien compris un ardent
défenseur du frais de ferroviaire si
possible dans le cadre du groupe SNCF ça
serait encore mieux mais bon moi
j'accepte qui est d'autres opérateurs
c'est pas non plus un problème
oui il faut ça commence par
l'attractivité quand même le plus
l'élément le plus important c'est la
réponse que j'ai faite à madame la
députée de la Drôme c'est la qualité de
service il faut être capable de d'offrir
des services de qualité on va pas forcer
les entreprises à passer par les
services c'est pas de qualité ça c'est
quand même c'est pas possible bon oui le
la première étage de la fusée c'est des
services de qualité avec tout ce que ça
veut dire les infrastructures les
chantiers les engins modernes du
personnel pour l'urée etc donc ça c'est
clair
deux après ben oui tout ce qui va
inciter à accélérer le reportal me va
bien moi donc pour être pour être
honnête avec vous et
dans cette commission je suis bien sûr
intellectuellement favorable à la
reprise des idées de type ecotaxe moi
aussi j'étais très déçu de voir que
alors que c'était une loi enfin quand
même on se rappelle au plan démocratique
c'est une loi votée à l'Assemblée
quasial illimité je crois l'unité au
Sénat voilà qui a pas pu être traduite
en effet on se prive de deux choses on
se prive d'abord de rééquilibrage du
repos du report modal puisque
on fait payer à la route une taxe et
donc ça équilibre par rapport au train
et deux vont se pris d'une recette je
rappelle que l'écotaxes et les
estimations c'était un milliard par an
un milliard par an si on mettait un
meilleur parent dans les eaux ferreux
français de plus c'est à peu près
d'ailleurs on n'est pas loin de ce qu'il
faudrait mettre en plus pour atteindre
le niveau souhaitable en matière de
régénération donc on se prive de deux
choses on se prive de rééquilibrer entre
la route et les rails et on se prive
d'une recette quand même qui compte en
milliard d'euros par an récurrente voilà
donc forcément tout dispositif allant
dans ce sens
permettrait effectivement auprès de
ferroviaire de se développer plus vite
et plus fort
si beaucoup avant de donner la parole à
Nicolas sangsue puis si différent je me
suis le rapporteur vous vouliez
intervenir
vous êtes bien rapide
vous avez dit Monsieur directeur
puisque nous penchons tout de même sur
l'historique de la libération de la
libéralisation
et nous avons entendu hier je crois le
ministre Jedi portait une appréciation
est-ce que l'appréciation qu'il portait
se retrouve un peu dans ce que vous nous
avez indiqué tout à l'heure c'est-à-dire
bon nonobstant le fait et je tiens cela
pour acquis
que l'ouverture à la concurrence n'a pas
été une réussite mais je vous avais dit
elle elle peut elle peut stimuler le
marché si le marché est stimulé
il y a un problème de marché
selon vous
que le ministre Djebari qualifié
d'immatures est-ce que vous pourriez
développer votre votre pensée sur ce
point et et je précède votre conclusion
peut-être mais ce que vous considérez
peut-être que aujourd'hui compte tenu
d'une normalisation
des aides publiques qui s'annoncent le
temps est venu de la vraie
libéralisation
alors
d'abord je je vais le dire clairement en
fait le rôle de patron de l'entreprise
publique c'est pas de faire la loi donc
la loi elle est européenne elle est
française elle est comme elle est bon
elle est résulte débats démocratiques
moi je suis très républicain dans tous
les sens du terme donc voilà mon rôle
est d'appliquer la loi alors en
l'appliquant la loi c'est de l'appliquer
très très avec beaucoup de
responsabilités et bien sûr en
protégeant au maximum mon entreprise ou
en voyant les opportunités de la loi
pour développer mon entreprise c'est
quand même voilà c'est normal
donc moi je rentre pas dans le débat sur
la concurrence on a débattu il y a pas
très longtemps d'ailleurs donc je
reprends pas le débat
à partir du moment où effectivement on
transforme monopole en marché parce que
c'est ça que ça veut dire quand on ouvre
la concurrence est-ce que ça veut dire
effectivement il faut s'interroger ce
qui qui prennent cette décision doit
s'interroger sur ce marché là quel est
ce marché qui sont en train de créer
est-ce que ce marché va va être marcher
dynamique qui a marché c'est quoi un
marché c'est la rencontre de services et
de clients ou de produits et de clients
et avec des entreprises qui pensent
qu'elles ont quelque chose à proposer à
des clients qui vont pouvoir proposer
leurs services et au fond comme toute
entreprise qu'elle soit publique ou
privées au fond qu'elle va pouvoir
gagner sa vie quand même cette
entreprise avec les services qu'elle va
présenter les coûts ça va générer va
trouver sur le marché des clients qui
vont être prêt à payer le prix qui lui
permettra de développer etc etc c'est
comme ça il y a du marché
en ce sens en ce sens on voit bien que
les les promoteurs de du marché
parle comme j'ai pu l'évoquer d'ailleurs
de simulation c'est à dire qu'une
entreprise fait quelque chose je vous
donne un exemple parce que qui est pas
dans le fret et il est honnête donc
parce qu'il s'est passé comme ça moi
j'aime bien être honnête
intellectuellement quand la concurrence
est arrivée entre Paris et Lyon puisque
les Italiens sont arrivés puisqu'il
pouvait le faire il est parfois que SNCF
voyageur a améliorer son service en
première classe entre Paris et Lyon oui
il est pas faux c'est c'est il y a une
amélioration du service bon voilà ça
c'est la stimulation c'est à dire que
vous avez un acteur qui arrive avec une
idée ou un service ça va l'autre il a
peut-être envie aussi de se mettre à
niveau voilà ça c'est et je considère
que c'est un côté positif ça c'est la
stimulation pour l'amélioration du
service pour moi elle me choque pas et
je pense qu'elle est pas mauvaise pour
le pour le client pour pour l'usager
par contre par contre une fois c'est pas
suffisant voilà c'est ça c'est ça c'est
ce qui s'est passé dans le fret comme on
a fait que ça et qu'on n'a pas vous
voyez tout le débat qu'on a pu avoir
autour des politiques publiques qui
auraient dû accompagner cette ouverture
à la concurrence et qui n'ont pas eu
lieu finalement les acteurs ont commencé
à se concurrencer entre eux le seul
élément de concurrence ça d'abord les
nouveaux entrants ils se sont focalisés
dans le fret sur ce qui était le plus
facilement accessible et peut-être le
plus rentable dans les trains complets
elle est très entiers c'est moins
compliqué notamment le combiné etc donc
c'est une partie du coup laissant
d'ailleurs à SNCF l'autre partie le
wagon isolé qui est pas qui est pas le
plus simple donc il y a une forme
déséquilibre du marché qui est apparue
puisqu'il y avait concentration des
nouveaux acteurs sur seulement un
segment et pas sur l'ensemble bon déjà
il y a un petit un petit dérèglement du
marché deuxièmement guerre guerre des
prix guerre des marges c'est à dire que
là forcément pour capter du marché les
entreprises commencent à rentrer dans
une lutte sur les prix et sur les marges
bon là encore les marges se réduits se
réduisent se réduisent dans une certaine
fragilité des entreprises du coup elle
peut plus investir suffisamment donc
l'investissement c'est bien compliqué
vous voyez et là le marché commence à
être déréglé parce qu'au fond on n'a pas
adressé l'amont la Mons et est-ce que ce
marché peut se développer voilà parce
que regardez le marché du portable ça a
marché parce qu'il y a eu le portable
c'est-à-dire les télécoms on peut
considérer que la que la l'ouverture à
la concurrence a pu fonctionner parce
qu'au même moment il y a ce marché
énorme qui apparaît qui est le portable
téléphone portable téléphonie mobile
voilà donc du coup il y a un champ à la
fois pour les nouveaux entrants comme
pour l'opérateur historique d'ailleurs
qui est allé voilà il y a un champ de
développement voilà donc c'est pour ça
que c'est très important que que que
l'ouverture à la concurrence se combine
avec des conditions de développement du
marché et là peut-être que le
développement d'un côté stimulation de
l'autre on a les ingrédients d'une
réussite
dans une logique de marché voilà où tout
le monde tout le monde trouve sa place
quoi tout le monde trouve sa place dans
ce dans cette dans cette construction
voilà alors après votre et c'est vrai au
fond votre votre proposition de
conclusion est intéressante parce que
cette espèce de paradoxe mais mais il
faut il faut parfois les apprécier c'est
que parfois effectivement la puissance
publique plutôt c'est pas la même du
marché c'est la position publique doit
intervenir pour faire en sorte que
marcher soit efficace l'espèce de
contradiction mais au fond peut-être
c'est une des leçons qu'il faut tirer et
qu'il faut retenir si on veut
effectivement tout en restant dans une
ligue de marché créer les conditions de
ce qu'on souhaite je pense à peu près
tous autour de cette table c'est du
développement du ferroviaire dans notre
pays avec une place légitime et forte
pour fêter SNCF et le pôle public
ferroviaire
ça s'appelle presque l'Ordo libéralisme
ce que vous venez d'évoquer
Monsieur Nicolas sangsue monsieur député
du Cher vous avez la parole merci
monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Président de la SNCF je vais d'abord
vous remercier pour vos propos sur la
défense du groupe public et du service
public ferroviaire et votre volonté vous
avez expliqué quand même que compreniez
pas cette
mise en demeure de la Commission
européenne qui semble un peu
surprenante au jour d'aujourd'hui après
les après les ce qui s'est passé le
redressement même si c'est même si c'est
fragile du fret et la et le redressement
est financier et en termes de marché moi
j'ai quelques questions
d'abord vous avez si je ne m'abuse je
crois que vous avez une lettre de
mission quand vous êtes nommé président
directeur général de la SNCF avant votre
prise de fonction quels étaient les
grandes lignes de cette lettre
concernant le fret
quelque chose de très simple
ensuite vous nous avez dit je j'étais au
Comex de la SNCF depuis 2006 2016 les
plaintes étaient connues on savait que
la Commission européenne
fouiller un peu donc vous connaissiez le
dossier quand vous arrivez aux commandes
fin 2019 vous savez qu'il y a ce sujet
même si il est pas peut-être en haut de
la pile mais c'est quand même un sujet
majeur quand est-ce que vous interpellez
le Premier ministre d'alors et le
ministre des Transports de l'époque sur
ce sujet et quel est leur réponse et
puis avez-vous des écrits sur cette
interpellation au ministre de au Premier
ministre de l'époque qu'elle cas
évidemment la commission d'enquête
serait très heureuse d'avoir ses écrits
ensuite avez-vous participé
depuis l'automne 2022 et les injonctions
de la Commission européenne qui
commencent à se faire même avant le la
lettre de de janvier avez-vous participé
avec le ministre Beaune a des réunions
des rencontres avec la Commission
européenne avant de recevoir la lettre
de Clément bon évidemment le 23 mai
dernier
deux dernières questions ne pensez-vous
pas alors que le fret frétille si je
peux me permettre que les concurrents et
que les concurrents ont retiré leur
plaintes qu'ils pouvaient y avoir un
plan alternatif à des discontinuités et
pensez-vous que ce plan alternatif est
aujourd'hui mort ou peut-on espérer que
la lumière de la commission d'enquête on
puisse avoir ce plan alternatif
un plan qui n'a pas été encore validé
par la commission européenne je le
rappelle qu'il est a priori selon les
dires du ministre il n'y a pas de décrit
de la part de la Commission européenne
au ministre Clément Beaune
concernant les sillons 23 sillons vous
nous dites
évidemment l'objectif c'est pas qu'il y
a un report modal vers la route ce
serait quand même un comble alors que
tout le monde veut la décarbonation des
transports vous savez très bien qu'il y
a un problème de conducteur je prendrai
un exemple très local j'ai un tout petit
OFP que vous connaissez qui a passé un
marché avec E parce que la SNCF n'était
peut-être pas mieux placée qui était
obligé de sous-traiter à la SNCF parce
qu'ils avaient pas de tractionnaire
voilà c'est à dire qu'il n'avait pas les
locomotives et le conducteur donc en
fait la SNCF est sous-traitant de ECF
sur un petit un petit trajet mais c'est
quand même un petit peu embêtant et donc
ma question est toute simple si il n'y a
pas de de solutions par le rail sur tout
ou partie des 23 sillons concernés ne
pensez-vous pas que l'on devrait
demander que Fred SNCF ou c'est filiales
puissent revenir dans le jeu et assurer
cela dans le cadre d'une volonté de
décarbonation et de maintien au moins
des des circulations par le rail et
dernière petite question annexe qui est
juste une petite précision si j'ai bien
compris les sessions d'herméois dermeva
et d'akem ont été imposées à la SNCF
dans le cadre de la reprise de la dette
de SNCF réseau je dis imposer est-ce que
c'est le bonbon
ok merci
les deux missions écouter de mes mois ce
qui est une lettre je sais plus
d'ailleurs c'est un formellement une
lettre je sais pas peut-être je pense
j'ai pas le souvenir d'avoir une lettre
d'ailleurs mais honnêtement le je suis
là moi enfin ce que j'ai retenu je suis
là pour appliquer la réforme en fait
c'est assez simple cette réforme loi
2018 mise en oeuvre 1er janvier 2020 je
suis recruté au fin octobre 1er novembre
2019 donc au fond ce côté là c'est que
là je peux pas je peux pas dire que je
savais pas quoi mais en tout cas la
réforme je la connais et donc je suis là
pour l'appliquer
voilà donc la mettre en oeuvre la faire
fonctionner
dans toute dans tous ces dimensions le
sujet du fret n'est pas explicite
d'abord il est pas trop dans la réforme
en tant que tel d'ailleurs c'est pour ça
qu'il est mon avis je en tout cas pour
être honnête de mémoire de mon souvenir
j'ai pas noté j'ai pas noté en arrivant
que j'avais tout de suite sur la table
dossier fret mais des discussions qui
interviennent alors à l'époque c'était
l'équipe l'équipe à Matignon qui suivait
le ferroviaire oui là c'est il arrive
assez vite dans le paysage et très vite
je prends position d'autant plus que le
covid doit débouler assez vite tout ça
s'enchaîne quelques semaines quelques
mois près sur le thème il faut sauver le
soldat Fred quoi enfin je veux dire il
est évident que
fait moi ma vécu mon vécu et ma vision
du groupe ferroviaire c'est avec le fret
avec du fret avec du fret alors il peut
se moderniser moi je suis pas con de la
modernisation tout ça ça fait je suis
ouais je sais que le monde doit
s'adapter que la SNCF doit s'adapter
voilà mais mais mais dans la SNCF dans
le groupe SNCF oui il faut garder une
activité de fret voilà c'est trop
important en matière de transition
écologique enfin je faut pas lâcher
l'affaire il faut il faut voilà donc
c'est un peu ma position et que j'ai que
j'ai tenu tout au long de ces de ces
quatre années
ça c'est mon les missions sur
alors des écrits non
il y a
si je réarticule parce que j'ai en
partie répondu à la question mais je
vais le refaire il y a un peu de phases
là dedans il y a la phase
[Musique]
ou en fait et chacune correspond un
objectif différent le premier la phase
l'objectif de la phase une c'est éviter
l'ouverture de procédure parce qu'on
sait bien qu'une procédure c'est quand
même pas facile à la fois par sa vie
alors ça dureté une fois que c'est
déclenché ça s'arrête pas comme ça et
par ses conséquences voilà donc il faut
vraiment l'objectif pendant la phase une
c'est éviter l'ouverture de procédure en
mettant en avant un certain nombre
d'arguments juridique
politique fait la politique fait la
politique le juridique fait du juridique
et redisant à quel point justement la
réforme permettait d'avoir coché des
cases avoir progresser il y avait des
plaintes on va aller lever et on avait
cru comprendre d'ailleurs de la part la
Commission que le fait de lever les
plaintes améliorer consciemment le
dossier puisqu'il nous avait expliqué
que c'était à cause des plaintes qui
pourrait qui serait obligé d'être dur
envahissait il couplait leur dureté avec
l'existence de plainte et on comprenait
des plaintes s'il y a des plaintes nous
on est bien obligé
la première compte donc même si ça n'a
pas été dit très dit complètement
directement ça établissait un lien
quelque part entre les plaintes et la
dureté la pollution dure de la
commission donc en enlevant les plaintes
on pouvait espérer du coup que
l'attitude serait plus conciliante voilà
mais bref bon voilà donc ça c'est la
phase une et la phase 2 c'est qui est
plus récente c'est qui c'est je vous dis
je vous redis ça c'est compliqué à
partir de l'automne pour des raisons que
je ne connais pas c'est-à-dire je
n'arrive pas à identifier la cause qui a
pu qui expliquerait une position
beaucoup plus dure de la commission qui
a débouché sur la phase 2 la phase 2
c'est ça y est la procédure est ouverte
là ça change la donne là il y a une
nouvelle donne et dès lors que la
procédure est ouverte je je que ce soit
clair je pense qu'effectivement il faut
pas prendre le risque de d'aller faire
trancher ça la Cour de justice il faut
il faut il faut accepter la
discontinuité et l'amener la manière la
plus propre possible en fait je je veux
être clair aussi dans cette deuxième
partie parce que les il y a une nouvelle
donne il y a ouverture de procédure
est-ce que j'ai participé à des réunions
oui
jamais avec le ministre donc les
réunions ministres sont Premier ministre
alors on les préparait avant il y avait
deux formes de préparation il y avait
une préparation interne
la SNCF et le l'État le gouvernement ge
aussi bien sûr qui joue un rôle
important dans ce genre d'affaires
et j'ai pu participer à des réunions
techniques notamment à partir de
l'automne quand on a vu que ça se gâtait
je veux dire où on à nouveau on a
expliqué nos arguments etc etc et j'ai
pu mesurer d'ailleurs la
dureté les fonctionnaires c'est les
fonctionnaires
compliqué de leur exposer leur exposer
les choses voilà donc je vois ce que
j'ai fait je n'ai jamais participé à des
réunions et le ministre dont je ne sais
pas ce qui est le ministre a pu dire ou
pas
sur
est-ce qu'il existe une alternative je
ne sais pas mais mais je vous donne mon
sentiment mais c'est un sentiment
quasiment citoyen pas de d'expert
je pense qu'on a franchi un certain
cassidité c'est c'est
quelle saurait les arguments pour faire
revenir la commission pour le coup qui a
ouvert publiquement une procédure c'est
du jamais vu quand même ma connaissance
je pense pas qu'il est précédent on la
Commission en fait la commission durable
est donnée vos arguments et dans ce
cas-là on appréciera parce qu'au fond
les à cette posture là elle dit
rendez-vous je sais pas quand fin 2025
ou 24 ou 24 fin 2024 et là je vous dirai
ce qu'il en est voilà donc
je
voilà ça serait prendre un grand risque
en tout cas je je pense que cette cette
option est peu et peu probable
sur les 23 flux c'est 23 flux
oui des flux c'est des flux
et la 5 et la 6 ça marche ensemble
effectivement oui un enjeu important
puisque c'est flux on a écrit à nos
clients qu'on serait plus capable de les
faire donc donc on les fera plus et donc
on incite nos clients à trouver une
solution
alors cette solution elle peut passer
par des nouveaux opérateurs bon et vous
l'avez dit ça se pratique dans la
profession ça aussi c'est l'exemple que
j'avais donné est indépendant des 23
flux il se pratique dans la profession
que parfois un opérateur prend les flux
se rend compte qu'il est pas capable il
se tourne vers un sous-traitant pour
l'attraction voilà c'est aussi peut-être
une modalité au fond qui pourrait être
proposée et c'est celle-là qu'on
envisage au fond c'est à dire d'être un
peu le sous-traitant de traction sur des
flux que les nouveaux entrants ne
seraient pas capables de faire bon en
tout cas toi c'est pas choquant c'est
une pratique du métier c'est quelque
chose qui se fait donc ça peut être ça
peut être la réponse après si au bout du
bout du bout il y a toujours pas de
traction il faut voir faut voir donc là
encore mais ça c'est l'État qui devra
apprécier cette cette situation puisque
ça consisterait à demander une espèce de
dérogation à la commission bon une
dérogation doit rester un peu
exceptionnelle si cette si c'est une
règle générale ça marche pas voilà ça
c'est dans si cette situation devait
advenir l'état appréciera s'il a lieu ou
pas de demander une forme de dérogation
temporaire sur tel ou tel flux
absolument vital etc voilà donc je
la réponse que je peux apporter à ce
scénario
merci monsieur le Président Madame
Sylvie Ferrer la député des
Hautes-Pyrénées vous avez la parole
merci monsieur
le rapporteur monsieur le Président de
la SNCF donc ma question
porte sur un élément que vous avez
rappelé
tout à l'heure vous avez précisé
préciser que les trains de fret donc
circulent la nuit au même titre
d'ailleurs donc au même titre que les
trains de nuit qui circulent aussi donc
sur de longues distances et donc il est
intéressant de voir en fait comment on
peut articuler c'est de transport de à
la fois de voyageurs et de marchandises
d'autant plus que le Président de la
République a annoncé la construction de
300 voitures pour 10 lignes de train de
nuit alors ce que vous pouvez nous
confirmer ce chiffre et s'est
investissement
et cela demande d'autant plus à la
puissance publique de continuer des
investissements pour électrifier le
réseau ferré sur de longues distances
alors ma question pour porte sur
l'opportunité donc de relier les trains
de nuit de voyageurs avec le fret comme
je voudrais avoir votre avis sur sur ce
point merci
alors il y a pas incompatibilité entre
circulation des traits et circulation
des trains de frais qui roulent à peu
près la même vitesse d'ailleurs donc et
la nuit en nombre de trains il y a de la
place quoi je veux dire si ici il y a
pas de travaux c'est les travaux qui
sont le frais à la circulation puisque
c'est le nombre de traits la densité de
train qui circule train de nuit plus
traine elle est elle est facilement
absorbable par la capacité du réseau
donc c'est il y a pas il y a pas
d'antinomie entre les deux non le très
le trait commun vous l'avez dit
vous-même c'est le réseau c'est toujours
pareil c'est c'est le réseau qui qui est
la clé du qui est la clé de la
résolution du problème on peut
d'ailleurs rappeler les chiffres en
question c'est en matière de de d'État
du réseau de modernité du réseau nous
estimons et ce chiffre d'ailleurs été
repris par les par plusieurs organismes
qu'il faudrait un milliard et demi de
plus par an de plus par an pour avoir un
réseau régénéré ça veut dire on remplace
les éléments les vieux rails par des
neufs les caténaires anciennes par des
voilà ce qui permet d'avoir un réseau
solide fiable qui tombe pas en panne
voilà donc c'est très important et puis
moderniser parce qu'il y a aussi on en a
un peu parlé jusqu'à maintenant des
sujets de technologie à la technologie
de l'exploitation ferroviaire change
comme comme dans tous les toutes les
industries le mot commun c'est
digitalisation en digitalise et pose
aiguillages etc donc on aurait besoin
effectivement de mettre aussi de
l'argent pour moderniser les outils qui
permettent de faire circuler des traits
sur le réseau français voilà donc c'est
ça dont on parle la matière des forces
supplémentaires au passage je le répète
donc font le point commun à trait nuit
et à trinfred c'est ça c'est un réseau
régénéré de qualité modernisé et ça ça
donnera les capacités nécessaires pour
faire circuler et les traits et les
trains-têtes bon sur le sur les traits
de nuit vous le savez c'est un contrat
qui nous lie avec l'État qui lui aussi
va être mis en concurrence voilà
décidément à partir 2023 la prochaine
fois que des trains des lignes de
training seront lancées les terres sera
amenés à mettre en concurrence la SNCF
avec notre opérateur sncboyeur que notre
opérateur ça c'est c'est
la loi la loi européenne transposée en
droit français et les matériels roulants
c'est l'État qui qui en tant qu'autorité
organisatrice des trains d'équilibre du
territoire de jour et de nuit voilà
devra effectivement investir dans du
matériel si on veut développer ses
lignes il faudra du matériel j'allais
dire aussi sur les lignes actuelles mais
là les 10 ans sont prises il y a un
matériel une auto motrice électrique qui
vont finir par arriver sur Paris Limoges
particulièrement prendre aussi en mettre
sur la transversale Sud d'ailleurs qui
passe à Toulouse etc jusqu'à Marseille
en venant de Bordeaux voilà donc ça
c'est bien à l'état effectivement de
faire les acquisitions de matériel
roulants que l'opérateur en fait fera
circuler pour offrir le meilleur service
possible à nos clients
et avant de donner la parole tout de
suite à Thomas porte j'ai opposé une
question très simple monsieur le
Président puisque il me paraît que
parfois dans les discussions mais on a
été un peu un peu confus sur le niveau
des aides publiques si on regarde le
redressement de la part modale du frais
de ferroviaire en 2021 et en 2022 et si
on regarde le redressement des résultats
financiers de fret SNCF en 2021 et en
2022 quelle est la part respective des
différents facteurs qui expliquent ce
double redressement selon vous comment
vous les hiérarchiseriez
je pense que les effets les plus rapides
sont
l'aide à l'exploitation les chansons
donnés au secteur dont une partie est
arrivée sur Frat SNCF notamment le wagon
isolé et certainement le la décision qui
a eu l'impact le plus rapide sur les
comptes parce que ça vient tout de suite
en recette et public qui a été validé
par la commission européenne pour les
publics a bien été dans la demande a été
faite par l'état français auprès de dans
la validité a été demandé a été accordée
comme ça se fait enfin je sais pas si
exactement la même chose mais enfin il y
a le même principe en Autriche voilà il
y a plusieurs pays européens qui ont ce
système là avec validation de la de la
commission puisque c'est bien le secteur
vous l'avez dit monsieur le Président
c'est tout le secteur qui est aidé et
après dans le cadre de l'aide au secteur
ben chaque opérateur reçoit sa part
voilà tout ça je pense que c'est
certainement le facteur qui a le plus
important c'est les autres facteurs
notamment portant sur l'infrastructures
demandant plus de temps voilà donc je
pense que le LED LED financière en
termes d'exploitation a permis de de
redresser la barre ou ou en ayant des
prix compétitifs et donc d'assurer un
début de report modal ou en restaurant
les comptes faire un effet cumulé les
deux je pense est important par contre
sur le moyen long terme on aura besoin
d'infrastructures pour consolider la
qualité de service et le développement
voilà donc on a besoin des deux
je suis le député Thomas porte puis
ensuite Nicolas sangsue vous avez la
parole monsieur le député
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Président moi j'ai trois questions
à l'homme de ce que vous avez dit si
j'ai bien entendu vous pouvez vous
pouvez nous confirmer que vous n'avez eu
aucune
réunion et discussion directe avec le
ministre des Transports Clément bonne
sur ce sujet là depuis que vous êtes
arrivé à la direction du groupe SNCF si
j'ai bien compris les propos précédents
que vous allez tenir ce qui paraît
surprenant quand même sur une procédure
de discontinuité qui engage un tel
niveau le groupe public ferroviaire une
partie de ses effectifs et l'avenir de
fret SNCF deuxième question vous avez
dit qu'il fallait une qualité de service
et que on pouvait pas contraindre les
entreprises à prendre à mettre des
marchandises sur les rails et qu'il
fallait une qualité de service qui soit
de haut niveau pour aller les chercher
moi j'aimerais savoir combien il y avait
de commerciaux à Fred SNCF en 2006
combien on a aujourd'hui combien on a
supprimé de conversion après SNCF pour
aller démarcher les entreprises pour
aller faire en sorte que les
marchandises viennent sur les rails et
troisième question dans le plan de
discontinuité présenté par Clément bonne
il y a une séparation entre
l'exploitation fret et la maintenance ce
qui n'est pas forcément une demande de
la Commission européenne pourquoi
séparer la maintenance et l'exploitation
dans ce plan de discontinuité en tout
cas est-ce que vous vous avez une
position là-dessus est-ce que vous avez
un avis et je vous donne pas si vous en
avez discuté avec le ministre puisque
apparemment non merci je crois qu'on
avait évoqué à plusieurs reprises que
dans la société dédiée qui serait lié à
la maintenance elle pourrait
éventuellement remplir des missions pour
d'autres opérateurs je crois me souvenir
de d'autres monsieur le Président vous
avez merci de me relancer parce que j'ai
pas été clair donc il faut l'être merci
de me permettre alors j'ai pas participé
à des réunions avec le ministre avec la
Commission le ministre a vu la
commission notamment la commissaire vers
Steiger voilà c'est là où j'ai pas
participé par contre avec le ministre
oui j'en ai parlé bien sûr je n'ai parlé
avec tous les ministres moi j'ai connu
monsieur djibari puis monsieur bonne
j'ai parlé de ce dossier avec les deux
ministres que j'ai pu connaître voilà
donc
c'est important de lever et lever lever
la confusion c'est fait
les commerciaux j'ai pas la réponse donc
ça peut-être qu'on vous la fournira
voilà on vous donnera le cet élément
d'information
j'ai apporté tout à l'heure une réponse
j'allais dire un peu de mentale j'allais
dire du mental c'est vrai que pendant
des décennies les gens du fret étaient
dans une logique un peu de réduction
donc c'est plutôt par le pilotage par
les coûts qu'ils essayent de retrouver
l'équilibre puisque les flux
disparaissaient bon là depuis 21 22 on
est on est dans une logique c'est à dire
oui il est possible d'aller chercher des
des clients nouveaux donc effectivement
il y a une inversion de mental de mental
un peu défensif on a retrouvé un mental
offensif donc comment ça se traduit en
nombre de commerciaux j'ai pas la
réponse précise mais on vous la fera
parvenir bien sûr sur la maintenance il
y a effectivement
[Musique]
deux de deux idées la première idée
alors dans dans l'ambiance discontinuité
vous savez que la nouvelle société doit
être le plus de la plus différente
possible de l'ancienne c'est ça pour
justifier du fait qu'elle est pas
apporté la dette il faut la transformer
pour qu'elle soit la plus différente
possible mais un élément différent c'est
qu'elle fasse lui là maintenance voilà
c'est c'est c'est un peu c'est un peu
buvette mais ça fait partie des éléments
ben voilà on l'a spécialise dans le
transport elle est plus transport et
maintenant bon c'est un des éléments de
différenciation c'est aussi l'idée vous
savez il y a une idée un peu de punition
là derrière on vous punit en vous
obligeant dans à réduire votre activité
d'où les 23 flux en moins et en vous
punit en cédant vos actifs ben un
atelier de maintenance et un actif donc
on vous punit en le voilà on vous
forçant à le CD alors il y a moindre mal
parce que ça va être céder à une autre
entreprise
SNCF fret mais mais mais voilà mais mais
il y a quand même cette double idée et
enfin là encore on fait du judo on dit
puis quitte à avoir une société de
maintenance des locomotives on va lui
faire maintenir les locomotives
voyageurs c'est peut-être pas idiot en
tout cas on va ouvrir cette possibilité
ou d'autres opérateurs ou réseaux ou
voyageurs ou d'autres opérateurs donc on
va en fait un centre d'excellence de
maintenance les cheminots les cheminots
sont capables de maintenir le locomotive
et pour pour le groupe SNCF et peut-être
pour d'autres voilà opposant des groupes
étrangers dans les dans les moyennes
maintenant sont loin bon si ils ont
besoin de maintenant sur le français on
peut le faire voilà donc on va essayer
aussi donner une perspective en matière
d'activité à cette nouvelle
société de spécialisée dans la
maintenance des des locomotives
je suis le député Nicolas sangsue
le Président Monsieur le Président de la
SNCF juste une précision sur une
question que j'ai posée où je ne pense
pas avoir une réponse quand vous êtes
arrivés donc évidemment vous avez
interpellé le Premier ministre Castex et
le ministre Jay Barry est-ce que vous
avez fait des écrits ou est-ce qu'il y a
des comptes-rendus de réunion qu'on
pourrait avoir à ce moment-là parce que
vous-même est très surpris aujourd'hui
de ce qui se passe et de la procédure
lancée par la Commission européenne et
donc ce serait bien qu'on puisse avoir
tout le déroulé savoir entre la SNCF et
l'État pour savoir comment on en est
arrivé là et et donc sous votre
président avoir tous les toutes les
lettres et compte rendu que vous avez pu
faire sur ce sujet
vous avez très bien on va regarder je
moi j'ai pas de souvenir de d'échange de
courrier officiel d'ailleurs je pense
pas après bon est-ce qu'il y a eu des
prises de notes des comptes rendus on
peut on peut regarder
oui oui non mais très bien non non mais
je vous dis non non mais c'est pas qu'on
vous cachez quoi que ce soit c'est juste
que je me souviens pas en tout cas avoir
voilà oui donc on va regarder donc on va
regarder ce qu'on peut trouver je me
souviens bien des des
postures j'allais dire des choses c'est
pour ça je vois bien les les deux étapes
qui ont pu prévaloir dans la gestion de
ce dossier difficile ce qui me permet
d'ailleurs à leurs yeux donc je on
s'engage à essayer de retrouver les
traces les plus écrites possibles de ces
de ces échanges à la demande de la
Commission peut-être aussi je me suis
rendu compte que j'avais pas apporté une
précision comme ça l'oralité toujours
comme vous dites un peu il faut faire
attention la session d'Hermée Vaï d'akem
c'est pas dans le cadre de la reprise de
la dette de 35 milliards c'est dans le
cadre de la dette du haut covid
dans les 35 milliards il y a pas
ermeva akem ça y est pas c'est après à
partir de 100020 on se prend le covid le
covid nous cause 10 milliards de
décalage de recettes juste énormes c'est
pas tout de la dette mais enfin il y en
a beaucoup qui se répercut dans la dette
pour compenser cette impact c'est là où
l'État je redis la réponse l'état fait
son travail en éjectant 4 mill iards et
demi dans la SNCF on travaille
d’actionnaire et nous on fait le nôtre
en terme de management à peu près le
même montant d'ailleurs on injecte aussi
4 milliards dans les dans les caisses de
l'entreprise en cédant herméva il y a
moi c'est ça pour pour réduire l'impact
sur les sur la trésorerie d'entreprise
si beaucoup monsieur le Président je
crois qu'on a fait à peu près le tour de
toutes les questions donc on va donc
recevoir dans quelques minutes pas votre
immédiat prédécesseur mais Louis Gallois
merci beaucoup de cet échange avec la
commission d'enquête merci merci
beaucoup la commission merci beaucoup